Fake loop!
That's right!
Get baited, everyone!
No loop here!
No loop here.
Anyway, give it up for day three!
Day three of Sleepy Bird!
I am... I am still... I am still... Eepy, unfortunately.
I'm... This is honestly how I've been feeling right now.
the last couple of days.
I think it doesn't help that I'm still coughing.
I think I'm not even like sick coughing anymore.
It's just my throat is just so scratchy.
I think it's just from, it must be from streaming, but then
I have to stream to make money.
So it's a negative loop right now, but it's okay.
Oh my gosh, I forgot.
Monday is our, is our last day for the project.
Zon boys wherever.
And then it's okay.
And then Tuesday.
Oh, oh yeah.
My sponsor on Tuesday got canceled.
So Tuesday is a free day for you.
Okay.
Tuesday will be my free day.
And so is Sunday.
Um, hey, the fix.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
It's the sixth streamer paradox.
The thing is, after I finish streaming, I stop coughing.
Because like, I'm not talking.
So my throat isn't getting like itchy.
For those who don't know, like, um, the reason why you cough
is because your vocal cords are getting irritated.
So my throat is getting irritated.
So it's scratchy.
And that's why I cough.
Um, but like, I'm getting less and less cough.
So that's okay.
But, um, I'm still really eepy today, so that's why I'm
sleepy bird is back yet again But some very important
updates.
I can't believe I'm I forgot about I forgot about the roblox
concert The Bruno Mars roblox concert on brain rot on what
the fuck a special from a brain rot what game is that anyway
I am so sad you know they had 12.7 million concurrent
players during the Bruno Mars concert today and I forgot it
was today and I missed out I know also another very
important update but Fortnite has announced another collab
skin I'm so weak I'm I'm so weak and they know I'm so weak
will but bugs bunny is going to be in fortnight now so oh my
god I'm I'm they they got me they know what i want they know
what i want they think pictures they're just announcing
every collab skin that i've always dreamed of like yes bugs
bunny is gonna bugs bunny daffy duck and lola bunny are all
gonna be in fortnite everyone they do what they don't
they're just farming me now They're just farming me for
bunny because they know I'm weak-willed.
I am the target audience.
And also, Adventure Time Season part one.
Finn and Jake are back on the story.
Oh, guys, I need a...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I need a...
Oh, guys, I'm sorry.
Give me a sec.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm sorry.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Well, I forgot.
I need to do this before...
Before I forget again.
Give me a sec.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Guys, I know what I am.
I'm sorry.
You can't fix me.
I know what I am.
I'm sorry, everyone.
This is who I am.
They got me.
They say oink, oink, dokey, new collab skin.
And I'm like, oink.
Jump little sheep.
It's really bad.
You can tell the point when they started announcing every
collab skin that I've always dreamed of.
I can't help it.
This is why.
Guys, guys, look.
Here's the positive thing, though.
At least I'm not into gambling.
Or CS skins, guys.
At least.
If it's any skin.
It's not CS skins, guys.
That's the bright side of things.
you know you know it's all about what's the word it's all
about the bright south there's a there's a phrase for it
it's it's all about the silver lining you know what
difference does it make um csgo doesn't have oh my god
kazuna i is in here too a csgo doesn't have adventure time i
could sorry i don't do not i'm sorry i do not really care
particularly much for fiona on kick i'm here for the ice
king and lemon grab also guys remember here you can use my
creator code and then you can do this and then bam um and
then oh okay and also let's see part one i can be finishing
now let's go wait there's bemo oh my god forgot repo man i
forgot got repo menace no i'm not really that jake the car
oh my god could be on jake wait they have jake bug dance oh
okay i'm getting that oh my god i literally sounded like fin
when he's screaming there i'm i'm so immersed right now it's
so immersive i let up i just let up my inner fin from 8 is
that like a show or something or is that their own character
all right let me see what other updates they have okay
luckily luckily it's just adventure time right now so so my
wallet is not as bad i i don't know um she is the very first
most popular the first breakout vtb but like i'm sorry i
could do not i i'd rather get adventure time
I'm sorry, but I rather, I rather get a venture time.
All right, here we go.
Sorry, I'm buying V-Bucks, right?
Remember, you can also use my code when you buy V-Bucks,
too, guys.
Wait, can you?
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, wait.
What's going on?
where's my cold i can last time okay maybe not wait did they
remove that it's okay i can use it it's okay i couldn't i
can use my code right now oh my god purchase oh my god i can
be ice king wait what's this unacceptable
ice kingdom all right nice i got everything i want um and
then also i'm got oh wait wait what kicks narrative uh i
thought this was like bacon pancakes not the same making
pancakes big making pancakes but i know no mom mom mom all
right we have to get oh my god wait i can have bemo wait i
could have jake as my okay let me Oink, oink, fuzz, solid
snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sorry, Buffalo Goons, but you were boring to suffer for
them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Let me grab the Adventure Time Bundles too.
Oh, my God.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me get...
I don't have a problem, guys.
I can stop anytime I want.
I just choose to not stop now.
This is a choice, guys.
This is a choice.
I swear I can stop anytime I want.
But I choose.
to do this to myself.
Sure.
Wait, do I not get the Bimo back?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I want to be Finn now.
All right, claim all.
Don't believe her lies.
Are you kidding me?
I want a Bimo.
Oh my god.
Wait, the dance.
Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Fuck, do I...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, do I...
I wish I could choose my Yoshi, and this is embarrassing.
What do you mean?
Wait, what's this?
Mona Lisa?
I swear, I do not know these new dances.
Are there any good dances, though?
Let's see.
I have no idea what any of these songs are.
Oh, shit.
The shake and split.
I feel like I've seen that before, but I don't know from
where.
Uh-huh.
Alright.
Oh, he's doing it.
Go, Jake.
Go, fit.
I said, Jake, go, fit.
Fake fan.
Oh, shit, is this.
It's the Will Farrow meme.
And I water the way.
Water, water.
rocks oh new kicks nah i don't like oh oh shit this is some
sick ass air jordans let me see how it looks on finn oh finn
you looking sick as hell your new air jordans oh my god hope
no one steps on them stop buying virtual kicks but guys but
he could be sick as hell i'm buying bmo i'm buying bemo
right now all right we have to get bemo and i'm buying the
jake dance it's oh my gosh but then the jake shoot though i
could fly no so uh no no no it's fine we don't need that we
can get i'm getting the jake dance give me a sec guys this
is iconic it's okay it's okay it's okay guys it's okay it's
i can stop anytime i want guys we have a buffer period until
bugs bunny drops Guys, we...
Yeah, it works.
It always works, by the way.
Creative code is jokekeeper.
Don't worry.
It always works, guys.
Please, please, I do not have a problem.
All right, it's okay.
It's okay.
Look.
Now, guys, look!
Oh, my God.
I could be Tom Kenny with Tom Kenny.
Okay, Tom Kenny.
And there.
We give him...
I give him?
We'll give Tom Kenny a skibbity toilet and then he can be oh
my god wait.
He should have look he's looking fly as hell so he should
have some Air Jordans with his with his fit.
Oh my god you're looking sick as hell Ice King.
Look at you go.
Alright.
Look at you go Ice King.
Look at you go Tom Kenny.
Look at you go.
Do it for the princesses.
I want a free foot.
This is not the God of War.
I came to see.
Look, this is like an opening act, guys.
It's the opening act chat.
We're just...
Oh, my God.
You can do the macaroni.
Look at...
Okay, this is the Ice King, though.
This is the...
Hey, macaroni.
And that could be now.
Now, that's the ice game we know and love, guys.
He wouldn't do that, though.
All right.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Now, okay, we're going out.
But wait, is the concert still going on?
Wait, I want to check out the Bruno Mars concert.
Is it still going on, guys?
Can we still get the...
Guys, just a little peek, guys.
Just...
I just want to know...
I just want to know what's going on there.
You know, it's literally their first concert, guys.
I have to see.
It's so important.
It's so important to all of us, guys.
is there are they still doing it where's the concert how do
i how oh my god i'm being picked up what the
oh it was like get out of here i'm being picked up when i'm
being kidnapped right now what oh my god i forgot that like
i forgot that like um I have VC on this is not good this are
you sure you want to join the VC service wait no guys I want
to know where the Bruno Mars concert is where is it
guys where's the Bruno Mars concert oh it's Prime it's Bruno
Mars is this not oh bye no any cons but how do i where's the
concert where even no one's gonna no
but but but i wanted to enjoy the it
was don't understand they had 12.7 oh there it is i see it i
see it i was on the wrong thing joint event guys guys come
on just one bruno mars concert won't hurt nobody
guys i heard it was really fun guys i'm i'm at the event how
do i Where is it?
I joined the event!
Oh?
What?
Who said that?
Ah!
Just...
I just wanted to...
I just wanted to to see Mr. Mars.
That's all I wanted.
I just wanted to see Mr. Mr. Bars.
I don't understand.
It's a jet.
Join to see it.
Join admin.
The admin abuse.
I'm only spawning the Bruno brain route one time.
So don't miss.
I missed it.
Oh.
Like maybe.
Maybe.
Wait.
What?
maybe I'll spawn it again I wish to join the event
I missed it it has 12.
They said they had 12.7 million people watching I thought I
thought we could watch it together guys I but
12.7 million how do you even play this so i purchase it new
bini pizza nini i want to buy you can i buy you can you join
my join my pizza nini hello
okay okay we can't watch bruno maz all right guys i guess i
guess i guess no bruno maz for me God's God of War time.
I'm so god damn lost.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the welcome.
Thank you for the gift of chip.
Thank you.
Oh, what's all?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God of War is having his feelings hurt again.
He's so cursed.
Oh yeah, for those who don't know, the reason for those who
are like, where's my Chibi Doki collab?
She is very sick right now.
because her throat just like me uh but not like me but uh
because uh she strained her throat a lot so the doctor
advised her that she needs to rest up uh so because of that
we're playing god of war yippee god of war time where's my
god now we're playing god of war all right minus 6.5 all
right boop all right let's see i think that was the yeah
there you go I got it uh let me make sure we have everything
sorted out so we're paying that's why today is god award day
I'm gonna try to do a long god award stream because like I
said let me play some eye drops real quick yep yep
because this is a long ass game
Where's my Marvel rivals, Doki?
I thought we were going to go to that next.
Anyway.
Anyway, yippee, got a water.
Yeah.
See, we eventually got to there.
Look, it was a...
We had to...
I was like a life update, okay?
I lost stuff I needed to check out, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I forgot.
Speaking of rivals, speaking of fucking rivals, I...
You know what?
Okay, I will have to say after, um, okay, no, you guys do
not understand.
So I did not realize what the fuck was going on on Tyler 1's
screen.
But, um, oh my gosh.
No, I, it is an accomplishment that we even got third place
in the end.
Because this is what was happening on Tyler's screen while,
like, Moxie and I.
We're playing our fucking hearts out.
So, we're just, this was what's going on on his screen.
Well, yeah.
So, the fact that, the fact that we even made it that far to
third was like, I'm proud of ourself like i'm really proud
of us we're even making it this far
yeah like like we we were we did it guys we fucking did it i
didn't realize how much of a deep bro he's a dad he has no
time for this guys he's a fucking dad it was a fucking
miracle we like beat super and got third place and even got
as close as we got against XQC's team because their their
weakest player is level 66 guys they're like beginner player
is level 66 apparently from what Moxie told me and then I
was like what we had three players that weren't even level
10 we
We had three players that weren't even level 10.
So I was just like, oh my God, that's crazy that we've made
it so far.
That's actually crazy.
Like we've made it so far.
I'm proud of us.
I'm so proud of us right now.
Especially after I saw Tyler's team.
After I saw Tyler's club.
But for the fucking plate, Mordel.
Yeah.
Um, yeah, so it was insane.
I saw this clip today.
And I was like, oh my God, that's what Moxie and that's what
Moxie was talking about.
I did not realize it was that bad.
I, wow, with this, you got, yeah, we got third.
Is that insane?
We, I'm so proud of us.
like I'm not I was I was proud of us even before I like
before I saw this and now I'm like wow we we really pulled
off a miracle right there we did a um we did a miracle run
for during the
tournament but why can't bro that tournament was 200k first
place literally each player gets 20k
If you get the first place, first place, each player gets
$20,000 for winning first.
It's literally for money.
Yeah, it's damn crazy.
That's why everyone was, like, trying so hard.
That's where we'll find Grow a Shrine.
Yeah, we're an elf then.
I see the elves continue their war.
Yeah, so the war's still going on.
What happened?
I thought I brought peace to the world I don't know if I'm
playing J3's tournament.
I just posted an LFT I just do it for fun.
I don't do it for money
I just really enjoy tournaments in general
Fimble winter hit Alphine hard no Storms have plagued
Alphine's deserts long before Fimble winter all right let's
go to dev and the content yeah i just like meeting new
people through tournaments living desert huh i don't know i
i just made an ltc like if any of the pro players want me
yeah and all the like super sweaty pros are joining so i was
just like so if i do get offers i will
would be the most fun as in we won't lose the most I mean we
will lose but like because I'm in it but but you know you
know what I mean hold on I hear something out there
something big it's in pain oh what do you hear with your
special ears don't think it feels like some kind of animal
How could anything live in a storm like that?
Ah, oh, wait, oh.
Not exactly a paragon of comfort, but the Dark Elves get all
the rest they can't.
Fire time.
Where is the other fire?
Wait, why is it just one?
Where's the other one?
No, I'm just cursed.
We finally broke our content creator slash content creators
slash non-VTuber rivals tournament run.
I literally had such a bad percentage win rate for that
tournament, for those types of tournaments, and we finally
broke the curse.
And it was with Tyler 1.
I'm glad it was with Tyler 1 for it.
I had so much fun.
I hope I get to play with any of these people again.
Everyone was so...
Everyone was really fun in the end.
yeah it's pretty cool oh there it is I just don't never look
down I just never I just never remember to look down always
and where's the last one I knew they were all here somewhere
Tyler is never getting moxie back no one ever listens to
women guys i remember i was like guys we should ban but how
do i get this it must okay there's some way to go over here
i was like guys what about like hello mantis bad they're
like no
there the temple of light oh there we go shrine is at the
top i just have to go down my So, at least like I don't do
it.
At least I can go down from here.
Women demon.
You don't respect your demon!
Like I don't respect women.
Guys, how much more aggressive can I be?
With bad hell yeah!
Sorry, I guess I wasn't aggressive enough with that.
Never let him forget.
You're right.
Bad Hella or I throw.
You're so right.
I should have been like, bad Hella or I throw.
GG's, we lose.
Wait.
Freya's brother?
Yes.
Cut from a different cloth.
Wait, who's Freya's brother?
Wait, Tear's Freya's brother?
Jiji go next.
I'm going Widowmaker.
Wait, wait, is Tear Freya's?
Oh, oh, Freya.
Okay, Freya and Freya.
Oh, Freya.
I was going to be like, there's no way my wife is a...
My wife is the sister of this fucking pussy.
There's no way.
My wife would never.
There's a barricade up ahead.
My wife would never allow this happen.
A rare material that can take millennia to form.
Majestic, isn't it?
Occasionally, the light of Alpine will bind to a rock and
crystallize.
Growing like moss on a fallen tree.
Truly a wonder of the nine rounds.
Change this color when lined up with a target.
What does that mean?
Reflect indicator will change.
Oh, oh!
What the fuck?
Where do I want it to reflect?
Oh, this is where...
Oh!
Hey, yo, bats.
I didn't know it could do that.
Oh, I guess that didn't matter.
Oh, I have to cut this.
Aha.
Whoops.
I just saw bats.
Oh.
I don't want it to reflect to.
But violence is fun.
I don't want... do I want to reflect to this rope thing?
Oh, there's more here.
There we go.
Very clever.
Clever golf.
Straight.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
God damn lizards, my goddamn invasive species.
What is he doing?
He's gonna explode?
Oh, it is.
Cool spy, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, gosh, I keep saying super chat.
Thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, yes, brother.
How was he involved?
long ago flair of the vanier traveled to alfheim where he
discovered a once beautiful land devastated by war using his
divine powers he set about cultivating a tenuous peace among
the elves oh peace is not an option to them I remember that
did you have to let this guy come with me he's like just
dead weight you hear that oh no oh shit oh shit they're
alive don't need to do this no war is always an option
that's right
oh my god and of course the pussy fucking runs away yet
again that's all he's good for and he ran away water water
yeah here there's no god of peace here i'm God of war.
Whoa!
I think you're hanging out with the dwarves too much, but
boy.
I mean, same, but like.
Whoa.
Next, he's going to start calling them knife here.
More will follow once we're inside.
Is there truly no other way?
Not like they're giving us much of a choice.
Yeah.
Don't even need to teach my boy.
Don't say out loud, boy.
You say it in here.
In your heart.
Oh, nice.
Best we move on for now, brother.
Are you serious?
Don't think we have the right tools for this one.
God damn it, we never have the right tools.
Oh, we got the...
What is that?
Oh, it's just a tribute.
What is this?
what is that how do i open this do i not have the right
twist again be like man i can't stand those leave lovers
cordon thank you let's see richad thank you thank you
let's say i think my boys hang out too much with the dwarves
we came in from the top last time didn't realize all this
was even down here it's an older gate built to promote
cooperation Oh, well, it looks like it didn't really work.
How do we enter?
Grab that wheel and I'll show you.
We just push it together?
What teamwork?
Yeah.
I'll go first.
Betrayus, let me know when I've reached halfway.
So, uh, what's happening right now?
This seal is meant to represent the balance of the realm
when Freyr was here.
Light and dark, working together in harmony.
Oh.
How's that look, Atreus?
Good, I think.
Father, I...
Unfortunately for Alfheim, Freya couldn't accept his
sister's decision to marry Odin.
He returned to Vanaheim and left this realm to its fate.
To be fair, the Aesir did set him on fire that one time.
Oh.
The door should have opened.
Are you sure it's balanced?
Yeah, but the realm isn't.
not anymore father try pulling it the other way yeah yeah
and here you keep pushing forward oh
is it just fully light now because it's not balanced no more
oh yeah cuz we like fucked over the dark elves it's no
longer balanced shall we
Yeah, all right.
No more dark elves.
What's that?
What's a dark elf statue?
Is that good?
That's just how they looked before the division.
The division.
We like, what's that word called?
The elves weren't always split between light and dark.
When you're like...
This statue depicts the elves before the war.
Before they discovered the power of the light.
Oh.
We like, are we the baddies?
Like, We did exterminate one type of elves, so I- Oh, let's
not think too hard about that.
Oh, we're not- Oh, let's not think too hard about that,
guys.
Solid light.
Guess something don't change.
Now we get inside.
Above the door, there's a light crystal.
Oh, it'll break it.
Weird.
They usually work.
Do you break it?
What?
Oh, we have to reflect it!
Oh, my God, I keep forgetting the reflection thing.
Yes, I see now.
The Twilight Stone briefly imparts...
No, we just...
You know, like, when we go over there, we, like, re-deck...
We, like...
What's the word called?
We rebuild a place?
And then, like, then, and then there's, like, expensive
coffee shops and then a place where it usually was, like, a
poor neighborhood.
We just did that.
That's not as bad.
We gentrified it, guys.
Guys, it's okay.
It's just gentrification.
Oh, shit.
Ah!
I've never seen the lake of soul so volatile.
My eyes.
Guys, it's okay.
We gentrified.
Making the light unstable.
So the base of this light well, that's the lake of souls.
Yes.
After the creation of the nine rounds, Wait, we can grab one
of the souls in here.
You won't be blue no more.
Wow, coffee is now 20 bucks.
And thus, the light elves were born.
Yeah, it's not great, but it's...
I don't like that.
As a gamer that lives in a dark in a room with no windows, I
don't like that.
that.
That's the light!
Like a fucking vampire.
It burns.
Though I imagine our light elf friends will be less than
pleased.
It's alright, they can just rebuild it.
Oh, it's alright, they won't do anything.
They know what I did to the other elves.
They don't want to mess with me.
Speaking of light elves, let me try talking to them again.
Alright.
It's just a light these two do their thing, brother.
Hey, bro, I don't... I don't think they're here to talk,
guys.
How could they do this to me?
I literally fucking helped them!
Get here!
Oh shit, it's alright, whatever.
I just feel like punching, I guess.
Oh shit!
That's fucking right.
Get punched, nerds!
Oh, there's more?
I know, I'm like, how could they like...
Okay, I'm this.
I'll get it.
I literally did so much for them.
I gentrified the area.
They should be worshipping me.
Alright.
Let's get out of here.
here here they came across on light bridges yeah where did
the bridge go i have an idea to get us across they're not
like the new coffee shop i built okay cool i don't think i
can oh that's what he did okay i was gonna say how the fuck
do i do that this way shrine awaits all right at least it's
very linear right now i appreciate that
their elves they hate everything yeah but i was helpful are
you going he's just looking around he does this sometimes ah
curious mind carry on all right honey thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you boy thank you the super chat
thank you thank you uh what oh uh uh erison thank you the
super chat thank you thank you burning for later on this
game has won the flash i'm like every time i look at the i
look at the thing i it's the light the fucking light temple
looks so different than i remember um the game has one of
the worst flash bangs i've had in my life my eyes alfheim's
light to enhance the temple and themselves i don't it was
been one month how did they change everything oh those were
just the foot soldiers they'll get more dangerous the
further up we go all right this is not so bad like that
wasn't so bad i was gonna say i gave them a month and then
now this whole place got re-renovated or some shit like if
that's because they're fucking trying to flip it turn it
back to its source to them the natural resources none more
so hi the light elf success came at a terrible price
withered into a storm-ridden wasteland soon after the
creation of this temple oh that's bad but that's really bad
there's more twilight stone up there oh so like to to make
this place look beautiful they literally destroyed the
outside was oh no i don't know jean oh it's right here
okay on this side here do you understand these poems oh
there's always meaning if you look hard enough brother it's
all in what you bring to it more like yeah i'll handle this
all right maybe that's not a great idea oh my god please i
need to look at the ground oh there friends salutations we
mean you no harm here should i help get back i was like do i
help him oh my god Oh my god, now they're just a full-on
nerds now.
Actual nerds.
I know.
I'll need my rage meter.
This is the only way I can solve my problems.
Okay, that's good.
These guys don't.
All right, give me the rage meter!
Oh my god, he's literally useless.
Wait, what?
quickly tapped it.
Oh.
Wait, I can shield bash.
I can shield bash you.
Let me shield bash you.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
Now he does something.
The fucking one time.
Come on.
I'm trying to shield bash you.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there's still one more.
Oh.
There's is the last guy i don't have xp oh there you go i
got xp i get it now why they keep fighting dark elves want
the souls and the light left alone but the light elves want
to keep using them that's the long and short of it hi oh no
which side is right yeah oh this is an elven conflict i said
as much the last time we were now fine oh no we picked the
wrong side guys i don't understand the dark elves were so
aggressive though if they explained their side maybe i
wouldn't have exterminated their kind why didn't they
explain it better i'm stupid
i'm stupid L problems, not our problems.
But we still, like, killed off the dark Ls.
Alright,
we gotta lower this.
Where am I turning it to?
Press L to holding the crown to aim.
Oh, my axe.
That's true, we're evening it out right now.
that is true oh it's right here okay guys we are we are
evening it out by by killing off the light elves then
there's no more and there's no more elves which means no
more conflict think about that
no more elves means no more conflict Is that how it works?
Oh, no, that's not how it works.
True.
Technically true.
You think about it.
There you go.
That was midway.
Let's continue our ascent.
I'm the genius.
I fixed war.
I should be a negotiator.
I Did it guys, I don't think that's the way up to the shrine
we know it's my way Oh, I see it now forgive my impatience
How do I tricky what?
What exactly we're bringing balance to the world
There's got to be a way to get your axe behind this great
right I mean, I can pull up.
If I pull it down...
Ah...
Oh my god.
Kratos would never be able to solve these puzzles for real.
I refuse to believe it.
I don't mean to speak out of turn, but the white marble wall
behind that grate, perhaps your axe can reach it.
what what what where
do i axe at oh yay it works thanks dear oh my god i'm so
smart let's go what do you think here i wasn't i you don't
have to listen i didn't even hear what he said uh oh wait oh
my god oh my god there's some useless item they have the
army guarding it
oh there we go i just slowly backed away thanks dear i love
they give us super chat thank you should get the stone wall
shield it lets you store energy when you block and then you
can bash them with the state of energy yeah but when i get a
parry it looks so cool though and then we'll be like
people think are like more impressed when i get a parry even
though it only happens like um once every 20 attempts but
those but that's the but that's the ray i'll take that oh
there he is what the fuck he took so much damage bye those
are those i like those chances
yeah when it hits it hits and then be like whoa quite the
collection of portugal so surprised why people are known for
their culture not surprised esteem Yeah, I live for that 20.
Oh, that's a little too high.
I live for that 2%.
Those are the odds I like.
Yeah, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
You fix war.
It's almost like you're some sort of god of war.
Exactly.
That's why I'm perfect at fixing war.
Oh, my God.
He's so fast.
Watch your right.
That's fuck you.
Whoa, shit.
Oh, my God.
I don't understand.
Why couldn't I?
Bam!
Look at that.
See, I told you it looks so cool when I hit.
When I hit, I hit.
It makes not hitting it so worth it.
Bam.
Have I been here?
No.
All right, nice.
All right, here we go.
Go up.
Let's see if I can upgrade anything.
I feel like I should be able to upgrade my skills now.
I feel like I have a lot.
I just need a better axe, honestly.
I should really...
Well, I should use my blades more.
This is a...
Oh, yeah, no, I can definitely upgrade all of this.
Arteus, are you good enough, boy?
Uh...
I will give him this.
Alright, I want him to be aggressive!
Whoa!
Tear can really jump.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, he went this way.
Where the fuck did I do this?
Okay, I...
I had to go here.
Oh,
wait.
If he's supposed to go that way, what's over here, though?
See, he didn't go that way.
Yeah!
He's getting the hang of it.
I've never seen the light elf have so much control over the
tower.
Yes, that's on us.
I have to do that here.
The Dark Elf King.
Guess he's in the light now too.
What's that for?
Oh this!
Oh shit.
Gravity!
Okay.
Oh.
Whoops.
I didn't do this.
I know geometry.
Okay.
Yay!
Ah, I see.
The timing must be precise.
I told you.
I know geometry.
Yay!
Just time, just time.
You find references that are Sony facts?
fact.
Oh, that's cool.
I'm ready to give him a super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I got a shortcut from this, too.
That's nice.
I love shortcuts.
This mystic doesn't see us.
There's Twilight Stone in the ground.
Ha ha.
Stupid.
Ha.
We can continue up this way.
How can he not see?
Just open your eyes.
Father, over here.
Yeah.
All right, we'll find Freya's brother.
With Freya's brother, then we can repair our relationship
with her.
Oh, it's that easy.
Whoa!
You know what?
I'm gonna try the...
I'm gonna try the flame blades.
I feel like I haven't done that in a while.
That's right!
Ah!
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, he did.
That's right.
Be aggressive!
I ain't letting you become the god of mischief.
I can't figure out how they're making light bridges.
Look at this statue.
If I can stop him.
Wee!
Is it working?
You think it's working guys?
Boopie!
Bum bum bum bum bum bum.
I should have moved it.
Oh it was just that easy.
Why the fuck was I throwing my axe there?
Oh I could have used it.
that to kill the other elves oh the crystal stomach light
bridges now the light elves wear them almost there allow me
all right i'll just use this to kill the other elves i dare
say he's beginning to enjoy the vandalism pretty soon he'll
be laying vandalism is fun it's okay when it's fun well
that's what they taught me look up see
Thanks, Tia.
Yeah, I think Guy's not as bright anyway.
I do appreciate that.
Why must they insist on these frustrating trials?
Oh, my God.
I can't remember the last time I visited the Norns.
Nor do I wish to try.
Gone, gone, gone.
I wish the last one.
What?
what is what is oh there it is i was like what the oh that's
cool oh i was trying to bash fuck this i'm angry now fuck
this dear dear you fuck are you pouring my combo dear oh the
one time you're aggressive the one fucking time really
It's such an asshole, dear.
You're really...
I fucking hate you, bro.
You're so useless.
You are so useless, bro.
Literally, what's the point?
Oh my god.
Why is he in my party?
Why can't I just fucking throw him out of my party?
Watch out.
I'm trying to do this goddamn puzzle and then Tear fucking
throws him away.
Where the fuck is the last one?
I see two.
Where's three?
Get down, Mr. President.
That's where the fuck is the third gun?
I looked at it.
I see one, two.
Where's gun number three?
God, I hate looking at that.
Right to the chest.
Oh my god.
What's here?
Oh my god, is it this?
Where have I been here before?
for wait this is new oh my there's like a hidden corridor
here
it's like battle music and the one elf is just waiting for
me i'm like give me a sec i'm doing a puzzle right now look
over there
all right there we go oh is he back oh my god I was like,
what, is he here?
And I get thrown, like, the fucking thing got thrown at me.
I was like, oh, where is he?
Are you serious?
God damn it.
Oh, yeah, you didn't see that.
You didn't see that.
Just need to do it a little quicker, I think.
Are you?
Oh, my God.
Okay, I have to do this again.
I get it now.
That's why there is a reflector.
There we go.
I also accidentally was doing the heavy throws.
Oh my god, I can't fucking open it because there's one
health here.
You know, my son was right.
He was right.
Oh my god, I'm just gonna...
Don't make me throw this at you.
Oh my god, fuck this guy.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I know what to do.
Oh shit!
Bam!
There you go.
Which fine, I got shield.
Okay, that's not one, that's two.
oh my god it's so it's coming my way it's very slowly coming
my way
there you go look this guy he just stands there it's like
tyler one
i'm joking i'm joking He's cool, he's cool, he's cool.
All right, let's go.
Let's go up.
It's okay, I just didn't tell him to go up.
Yo, chill.
All right, up we go.
He's waiting for the calls dokey i come i can make my own
angle there's any way to stop the elves from fighting each
other had frayer not abandoned the realm a lasting peace may
have formed but now can we really place all the blame unfair
this war started long before his that is true though he had
the power to heal this land and end the war did he not he
made his choice the wrong Okay, well, you're not doing
anything better.
I will have to say, like, he didn't make a good choice
either, so should you really judge him?
Yeah?
Like, you weren't any better than him.
Like, bro, you got your own problems.
Ah, that should work.
You have a failed rebellion.
Everyone has problems and everyone judges.
Not me!
I'm perfect!
So how am I supposed to go?
Except don't eat.
Oh.
Am I looking at the wrong way?
Is that not where I'm supposed to push it?
Yeah, there's no other way for me to push this.
Oh!
There we go.
I was gonna sit.
That doesn't make sense.
Oh!
Okay.
Huh.
Maybe from this angle?
No?
What angle should I hit it from?
This angle?
There must be a way to move this statue.
still so far which angle should it I thought that was the
right angle oh wait wait wait I figured out yeah there's
no other oh wait there is another wing oh my god I didn't
see that about up there what the fuck are you pointing at
boy how would we shoot that I don't think he can oh I see it
now the wings are connected back here hey father yeah I
could tell it's up there but I can't from below I
don't think it reached up here.
Yeah.
I don't even know where it is.
Okay, up where?
Yeah, there's no way I can reach that.
Oh my god.
Okay, so...
I'm perfect, guys.
That looks right.
I'm perfect.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Tear.
The last time we were here, we killed the Dark Elk King.
That's unfortunate.
I'm so smart.
I wondered what became of Spartan, daughter.
We had to defend ourselves.
But when he died, he told us we helped the wrong side.
Fine job, brother.
This way, we're almost there.
It's okay.
We're going to even things out.
Don't worry, guys.
We're evening it out.
Yeah, geometry!
That's okay, guys.
I'm EP.
Do you still hear something wounded out there?
I think so.
Who is it?
Is it a storm?
Is it a bear?
Once we've uncovered a mysterious seer's hidden prophecy.
Ah!
Okay, we'll look on the ground.
I'm going to look at the ground.
I can't.
Oh my gosh, it's so obnoxious.
That is actually so obnoxious.
It is way too bright.
Oh my god, my eyes adjusted to it.
Thank God.
adjusted to it
what did he say i was not listening my i was she was too
bright what's supposed to do
there's some sounds down up there is quite nicely with the
twilight oh there it is i didn't see that good job boy you
actually did something useful today maybe if we allow me to
speed this up What?
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I did it.
At your service.
Yeah, it was too bright that I couldn't hear interfered with
my ears.
Wait, there's a chest over here.
Nothing.
What's wrong?
Wait, how do I get over there?
Mother inside last time.
But I can't anymore.
Her soul is one with the light now.
United by forces.
How do I get over there?
She is at peace, Atreus.
Yeah, actually useful for once.
And Father went inside the light.
He said he...
You went inside the light of Altheim?
Yeah.
What's wrong with that?
And yet here you stand of sound mind and decidedly not...
Yeah, like it's hard?
You must tell me, Kratos.
What did you see?
That memory is for me alone.
But I felt only moments pass.
Didn't feel like moments to me.
I was trapped.
Atreus overcame great odds to save me.
One could but only imagine.
Well then, grow as Trip-Tick awaits.
Oh, but what about the loot?
Can I go back down?
I can't even go down!
What the loot?
Oh my god, I'm stuck in like slow mode too.
That's the worst part.
Is there any more?
Do I have more upgrades?
Oh no, I finished my upgrades now.
It's just my boy.
Like, a second.
Double check something real quick.
I just realized po po po po po po po po.
I just wanted to double check something real quick.
All right.
Off the walk.
It's the walk of shame.
So, did you ever meet Groa?
Many times.
Simple-minded.
Thing on the super chat.
Thank you.
Conversation was difficult.
You don't even know what holds.
That's one thing I didn't know.
I know all the other stuff.
They give the super chat simple-minded.
Thank you.
But stop.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Your chieftain looks super cute.
You and the chie-chie-chie-chie first looks very jar-but
today.
Thank you.
It was super chat.
I'm just EP today.
Don't worry.
Next week, I'm less EP.
Did we skip the cutscene?
How do we skip it?
I didn't press anything.
Touch the lamp.
Touch it.
No, Yawana.
Come on, Kratos.
Touch the light.
What are you doing?
Boy, you cock.
I heard something.
Calling for you.
Boy, I'll quave the forbidden light.
How dare you get between me and my wife, boy?
No!
touch the light Kratos my wife he's very pleased but I'm so
lonely I'm so lonely boy how could he deny me we're almost
there huh they've changed some stuff last time.
There was all this hive stuff up here.
So many dark elves.
I...
All this time, I thought the dark elf came.
I thought all the dark elves were...
Yeah, say it.
We're what?
Yes.
Say it.
What were they?
What were the dark elves are?
What are they?
What's the right question?
Is there a right side?
Exactly.
What do you think?
Dark elves are what?
there's no right side in this wall i i don't know then
perhaps you shouldn't pick one yeah which side is the right
side boy light side or dark side
what are you implying
um Because he won't stop me from touching my wife.
Technically, I'm touching it right here.
Whoa.
That's because he hanged up with the dwarves for too long,
guys.
Not my upbringing.
I didn't raise...
I didn't raise a racist.
I didn't...
He said it.
I fight everyone equally.
Guys, I fought everyone equally.
In fact, I'm out here going to wipe out the light elves.
I did like the tree hugger.
Maybe that was the problem.
Yeah, I don't discriminate on who I kill.
I kill everyone I see.
So him, him saying all that, that's not on me.
Wait, if he goes this way, then I'm going to go to the right
side.
I knew it.
I knew there was a chest here.
Yeah, I raised him to hate everyone.
Exactly.
No matter what kind you are.
I just I'm just an asshole always did enjoy hiding their
secrets in plain sight wait until you see this Huh Touch the
wood boy touch it
Okay All right, what do we see yes here we have drew a
search for her missing husband She was relentless in her
attempt to find him meditated for weeks on end unfortunately
she found something else a vision of Ragnarok word of grow
his vision reached Odin he sought her out demanded a private
retelling didn't like what he had oh why did he just kill
her she's just a messenger that's the I don't know just a
messenger you just killed the Prophet curious whatever I i
know some giants thought so but ironwood isn't anywhere lad
it's a concept a metaphorical paradise it's not real
presumably grower requested her ashes be returned to yoden
high while her soul found peace in the light difficult to
imagine odin respecting those wishes hmm the champion i
think it's supposed to be is that you you assume too much
yeah i was gonna
are slippery by nature you're not there yet more obvious
than others oh no that was the end of everything so this is
it there's nothing we can do to stop it there must be a way
it's okay we'll just go to another dimension i did that last
time look there's other mythologies we could go it's you
fighting in ragnarok no what i don't i can't what why not
What's this thing?
Yeah.
That's new.
Huh?
Asgard is destroyed?
Wait, Tyr's gonna destroy Asgard?
But the other realms thrive?
Oh, he's gone.
He's gonna kill Odin?
And Odin dies.
Yeah.
She lied.
You're all alive.
Of course she did.
Odin's working off a false prophecy.
So then we can win Ragnarok.
We can beat Odin.
We are not present in any of this.
But that was Tyr leading the charge against Asgard.
Plus, Hell's army was there.
And the elves.
Champion.
Okay.
Whoever that is doesn't matter.
for the first time we know something odin doesn't we just
saw we can win so in the prophecy like the original prophecy
odin wins to define my choices but but we just saw no atreus
this is wrong why is it wrong don't you want odin to be dead
come there is much so like the original prophecy that we
thought we knew odin wins is it like odin wins the war
how come he didn't like it
oh the original is destruction of everything we can't stop
ragnarok but we can win it and then the actual prophecy is
that Asgard dies.
End of all realm.
What the fuck were it?
How did...
What?
What the...
I was just like, I'm done with my prophecy.
Oh my god.
What is he doing here?
Okay, so the original prophecy was right now ends all
realms.
And then he had to kill Tear off.
He had to imprison Tear so that doesn't happen.
But then she didn't tell...
that it was just Asgard's realm and Odin dies.
What the fuck, would you not be happy about that?
Bro, you were like, fuck Odin.
So, what'd you see?
A lie.
Roa lied to Odin.
Ragnarok isn't the end of everything.
Yeah, it's just the end of Asgard.
Yeah, everyone.
The destruction of an entire realm is it?
To say nothing of its citizenry, it's wildlife.
Okay, everyone fucking hates Asgard here.
Goddamn hippie.
Enough.
There's much to discuss once we are safe at home.
Yeah, you fucking hippie?
Come on.
He fucking imprisoned you for hundreds of years.
You didn't eat water or food.
You should be happy about this.
Yeah, shields.
Tears from Asgard too.
Yeah, he can just go move.
We can move.
Oh, Runic 30, though.
Ah.
Wait, that seems so cool.
But then my defense goes up.
I'm going to craft this to see how much I need to upgrade.
Okay, can I upgrade this?
I can't upgrade this.
Okay, never mind.
It doesn't matter.
I can't even upgrade it.
Hmm.
I can't upgrade anything anyway Wait, can I in fate's
injury.
Oh, of course not just move
There's only one thing.
It's like the trolley problem To be fair everyone in Asgard
are assholes anyway, so like who cares Throw assholes tier
they literally eliminated a bunch of people
So it's fine Don't worry, bro.
Yeah.
We can move here.
See, this place ain't so bad.
What do you mean I got the wrong armor?
I think I got it.
It's the right way.
Really?
The one I have right now is better.
Isn't it?
Yeah, because this is less strength.
That's like 12, and this one's 18.
Yeah, I think my armor's stuff is fine so
he doesn't we found out that it's just his only and why the
fuck why was he even particularly mad no reason to be that
man we just found out that perhaps we should focus on oh
shit oops oh i just realized i don't have my knife i'm just
literally Bye-bye.
That was fine.
Smashy, smashy!
Yay!
God, why does he get so little?
My boy gets so little XP.
Have you ever been to Asgard?
I don't think... I don't think Kratos been to Asgard, right?
Pretty sure.
That's right.
I'm angry now!
Just for you!
This is a special frozen and then i'm lessing i'm like all
right i'm good now what the fuck that's right i move first i
have more speed stats than you
oh he just wants to kill my boy that's fine i'm fine with
that
i don't think he's allowed an ass guard i'm pretty sure
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Where are they?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, they're so far.
That's fine.
I'll just let my boy do all the way.
Oh, my god.
The stupid fucking pole.
The stupid balcony.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
That's right.
The gift of strength!
That's right!
Watch your right!
That's right.
Fire!
That's right with the power of fire!
Oh shit.
Let's vanish this.
It's just a flesh wound.
Oh my god, never mind.
Oh my god, but that looks so sick, though.
There you go, it's fine.
Got my HP back.
I don't know, I still like the axe more.
I think the axe is better.
IMO.
Alright, what the fuck is...
Oh, it's the little lizards.
Wait.
Oh shit, like, what the fuck is so fast?
Oh, hey, nice.
Friendly fire.
I love that.
Thank God for friendly fire.
But where did he go?
Oh, I can go both ways.
But I want to go back up.
Wait.
Where there was loot down there?
I didn't check.
I didn't double check.
And also, it's my wife's axe, too.
I feel closer to her when I use it.
You know, it's more romantic.
You know?
It's so romantic.
I use the axe that my wife has.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
That's you.
There we go.
That was you.
We need to keep moving.
He's really worked up.
Yeah, why is he so worked up?
Like, Where are we going, bro?
What?
Oh, wait.
Look.
Yeah, but it has your previous...
We're thinking about now, okay?
This way.
Yeah, but like...
That arc is over for me, alright, guys?
It's all about my new...
My new dead wife.
We gotta move forward.
This is about my new dead wife.
Not my old dead wife
Yeah, out with the old in with the new
All right, nice
We killed someone oh my god alpha
Bro that was like It's fine, I'm gonna use this.
Oh, he's like, I'll kill her!
You become welcome back, God of War.
I'm so proud of you.
Finally!
You have finally become the God of War!
You're back!
Yappa!
All right, that's fine.
There you go.
Fine.
Boom!
That's fucking right!
Let's go, boy!
It's family bonding time!
Oh, shit!
The alpha!
That's right.
I'm gonna make her a beta right now.
Against the fake!
What?
Okay, that was bullshit.
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
Did not see that.
He's like, oh, it's just a flesh wound.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Did you see that?
Oh, oh, my God.
Okay, that combo.
Okay, now...
Get parry!
I told you it's so much more sick!
It's more sick when I get those!
That's fucking right!
And you said you're alpha.
Three parries in a row!
How does she do it?
yeah oh i can upgrade my accent let's go wow wow this was
going on he's still grieving okay okay i literally just
killed the queen of light elves what it is far from over
what the fuck
it's gonna be okay here you've seen what is to come kill
wife i told you i would not follow you sad here i am
dragging an innocent why and marching towards the
destruction of asgard what choice do we have there is always
a choice i will not lead you to war i'm the new alpha i
won't why that is so messed up i don't want to fight but
with you three there is no avoiding it great oh wait i
forgot my head is also a person unimaginable pain and
suffering well let her go this is worse the god of war you
cannot just oh oh
but he can grab the force solo oh shit hold on over here
your change oh it's for the light bridge Oh!
I didn't realize that was for the bridge.
That's why you...
I thought it was like... I thought it was just for fun.
Nice.
We homies now.
You saved my life.
Oh.
He's a hero.
Yeah, I thought he was just regretting for killing the elf.
So you wanted to give her up your proper burial.
Oh, I got extra stun and damage.
Oh, that's cool.
A sovereign hunter.
Then you was super chetting, thank you.
I thought that's what it did.
Thanks.
And I'm sorry about before.
I...
No.
I am sorry.
I should never have come.
What do you mean?
We shouldn't linger.
Also, I hope the sound is alright.
I pushed it up a little bit more than normal than my last
stream.
So I hope it's not too loud now.
Sound and good.
I just want you guys to be able to hear the dialogue.
Look.
I just want to do the right thing.
And according to prophecy...
Speak no more of prophecy.
War will not give you the purpose you seek atreus only
slaughter so what are we supposed to do roll over do nothing
enough we will discuss our next move when we are out of
danger
ah got my silver
is it time to go home are we leaving elf land We're limiting
all the light elves.
My job's not done yet.
Guys, equality, guys.
Equality!
Oh, shit!
Okay, I guess.
Fuck equality, I guess.
Wait, Dark Elves?
I thought we killed them all.
Wait, they're back?
I thought I got rid of all of you.
Oh, guess not.
All right, they're still around.
I mean, that's good, right?
That's good, guys.
That's good.
Oh, yes, I...
We did...
See?
We didn't commit a crime.
Technically, not a crime no more because they're still
alive.
I just killed some dark elves.
Technically, technically, not a war crime.
I didn't we didn't extinct them through here and that's the
last of the dark elves we'll let them fight a little bit let
them fight dear are you okay okay then we're mad so I should
like freeze my axe real quick ah moves right double boom
okay tier you got stop nice we
got some rage too look at this oh they're still fighting
who's gonna win boom get rock oh shit oh I think that layout
is lost but that's okay we're rebalancing it guys that's
okay try to make the numbers more equal guys remember
equality here equality let's go let's go just a like jogging
elf pack all right it's fine where's the other guy wait oh I
want oh Yeah!
Wait, is it still there?
Oh, it does not.
That's fine.
Okay, guys, come on.
Chill out, chill out, chill out, chill out.
Oh my god, fuck this.
I'm going to be angry.
It'll be a shame if there is a boss fight after that,
though.
I would...
It will be a shame.
That's why I put you out of the sky!
plane?
Father, this way.
All right.
Which way?
This way?
But this way might have loot.
Oh, it's the same way.
I don't know.
I'll wait for him.
Yes, guys, for planes only.
You have no rights.
Did you get a license to fly at this time?
Surely there's no boss right here, right?
Yeah.
Fair enough.
Oh my god, she's actually just frozen.
That's good for me.
Yeah, this is a no fly zone.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, again!
That's okay, right?
Okay, I didn't do that.
Okay, look, okay.
I might have missed that though.
It's alright.
I can just be angry.
No way.
I told you, it's just cooler when I hit that 1%.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's fine.
I'm strong, though.
What the fuck?
Wait, that's you.
Yeah, how dare you?
You interrupt my combo.
Wait, what?
No, we're a team.
Wait, why are you ditching me?
You're not even heading there.
You're just standing there, dear.
Oh, shit.
That's not good.
Okay, wait.
Do I have...
No, I thought I had, like, the combo thing.
it but that's okay now i do yeah
i do now oh no wait that's a woman it's all right equal
rights equal fights it for equal rights i don't discriminate
boom i was like woman that's all right I fight for equal
rights.
Oh my god, he's poking me.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I was gonna say, what?
Jesus Christ, he's so nimble.
Alright, let's get that thing.
go to go up or down oh definitely up wait unless hmm upward
down which way is the right way can we leave now please
almost there this should be fine yeah oh we're back here.
Open the gateway, please.
Okay.
Back to the dwarf place.
What?
Oh, shit.
You want war, Atreus.
See for yourself the legacy this one has left for the
barons.
I've had far more than I can stomach.
What?
What is this?
path we do not need to rush we should see this desert for
ourselves what is this place look i know we can't trust
prophecy but i'm not sure we should just ignore what we saw
either we are not ignoring it we will discuss it back home
the cadmians i wish to search for the wounded animal you
heard earlier oh the wood wounded animal yes oh my god we
yeah we're letting Yeah, lead the way.
Oh my god, these guys.
We find a way past this hive matter.
Did not...
There you go.
I did it.
I did the... Oh my god, it meant nothing.
It was just a little...
Remember this mechanic thing?
Oh my god, it was just a reminder.
Yeah, see, I'm a nice dad.
Guys.
See, I'm entertaining my son's little side quest.
I'm such a good parrot.
You ever think of kicking meat with those blades of yours?
No.
They would foul the meat.
Oh, because of the magic on them?
The blood.
Ah, yes.
Carry on then.
Oh, hey.
Hail, fellow travelers.
I should be able to upgrade my axe.
Yeah.
Because I remember I got the axe upgrade.
yeah I think it was just the axe though yeah I am as always
at your service are you surprised it's just me I know my arm
is thick as hell though all right let's go find the
companion accessory slot select your command companion in
the armor huh oh shit oh oh he had a new one oh nice nice
boy you learn a new skill growing up so fast.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What?
What are these animals?
Goulon, native to Vanaheim.
Not sure what they're doing here.
Oh?
All right, free ride.
Where is his owners?
I'm trying to pull a sled.
Lucky for us.
Domesticated Goulon.
Most unusual.
Yeah Who domesticated them wait wait wait that's that has to
be loot right there.
Okay, we gotta We're lining it up perfectly.
I knew it random barrel in the sand.
That's gotta be loot I gotta make sure I hit those.
Yeah Wait Oh, I can just get off of it whenever I want.
I'll grab this chest
Is it Freya?
Freya?
prayers thing should be his right why else would there be
like random fucking whoa domesticated wolves here any
particular direction to find your wounded animal oh no this
is just enjoying the weather I can't hear anything out here
perhaps we find a cave first to catch our bearings oh look
attempting treasure chest Damn this, Sand.
No!
No, not Sand.
The goddamn Sand.
Look, there's a cave entry.
Oh, yeah.
I hate Sand.
It's coarse.
Yeah, the top is literally still breakable.
I don't understand.
This cave extends underneath the desert.
Is the creature within?
Yeah, sounds like it.
We'll find it if we keep going.
What is this place?
I have huge for the Dark Elves by the looks of it.
One of the few to meaning know that they're barred from the
temple.
Ah, great.
It's okay, we're just making sure we kill equally.
Need equal amounts of Light Elves and Dark Elves, guys.
I just needed to make sure.
That's fucking right.
here.
This is my area.
We're bringing balance.
There you go.
That's everything.
Yeah.
I did not know I could do that.
That's actually cool.
Yeah!
We can never is welcome back, sad lad.
Because I cut off his wings.
That's why he died.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he just kept going.
I was like, what the fuck?
He just kept going.
Oh wait, this is perfect.
And again!
Alright, nice.
Swing!
Swing, better, better, better.
Yeah!
Sorry, don't worry, you'll see your wife in hell too.
Yeah, let's go.
Now that I know more about the Dark Elves, I wish we didn't
have to fight.
That's not what I want to do.
Yeah, that's on them.
Ah, this is self-defense.
The last time we were in Alphan, can you really blame them?
How the fuck do I hit this right?
Oh, there's...
I knew it.
I knew there was something up here.
And I'm going to go here.
I fucking knew it.
Oop.
I knew it.
Tears, stupid teachings.
You're infecting my boy.
No, remember the war!
And how good it felt to be aggressive for.
Remember!
Do you remember how good about to kill boy just remember
don't be like him
one where's the other one
only see one
i swear to god i swear to fucking god if it is 20 miles away
i swear to fucking god
goddamn puzzles this head was meant for bashing not for
stinking
the pink still oh my god i can't even go back It's not
always like that some animals are just I feel what they're
feeling, you know And whatever this thing is The pink still,
oh my god, I can't even go back I can't even go back I found
Oh, I thought I am capable of curiosity No Okay
I didn't realize I Didn't I thought it could come back.
Is that not enough?
Do I have to go from this side?
Because I can't throw my axe from here.
Yeah.
Can I?
What?
And how do I do this?
Oh, there's the other side.
Yeah, because I can't throw my axe from this side.
But there is another way.
Oh, how open?
Oh, down.
Get the shit out of here.
Get out of here.
Oh, there it is.
Are you fucking serious?
Okay.
Oh my god, that's it.
Wait, how the fuck do I do this?
Oh my god.
Get out of here!
I'm trying to think!
Oh, I can open this.
Oh!
Yay!
Wait, if I can open this, how the fuck do I do the thing up
here?
Can I open this?
No, I can't.
Oh no.
Not thinking.
Yeah, now what?
Oh!
Excuse me?
I thought I was so smart.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, hey, I got...
I mean, okay.
Maybe.
I don't know, it was just a wild guess.
Sick throw.
Oh, no, I'll get over there.
I talked to animals or enchanted rings or whatever.
Much has changed.
Okay, boy, a personal space.
Well, yeah.
I'm just trying to figure out why you'd help some random
animals.
Personal space?
No, no, it is.
I'm just surprised it's what you want too.
Alright, now I can climb.
He actually was like...
He was way too close.
And I felt...
From my manlyhood, I felt uncomfortable.
Yes, there we go.
And now I can go back down.
all right there we go nice all right we figured it out all
right
okay this is the slowest
i forgot where the others oh my god it was right here there
we go oh my god that was that i was like oh my god that i
felt Like, I took too long.
I was like, I hope I have enough time.
Because I forgot it was left or right.
Oh, shit.
Where's my...
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to assemble geometry right now.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
Wait, he's so fucking tanky.
Well, I just noticed that.
He's so tanky.
That's right.
They got my rage meter.
Yeah, no, this guy was tanky as hell.
Holy shit.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Get out from the sky!
And Tartuari right here.
Wait, that's not him.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
How the fuck?
Get out of here!
Okay, it's nice that they waited, though.
Oh my god Yeah fucking no there's so many of them Okay
Really that didn't parry That should have been a parry man
Oh my god Jesus Christ I can't see Oh no oh no I can't see I
can't see I'm blind
So yeah, I got the meds All right, nice reset Why are they
so mad at me?
I don't know what I did wrong What did I do wrong?
Just trying to restore balance to the world All right dark
elf Lord Jesus Christ All right, at least I killed the
alpha.
Yeah, except killing.
I'm just trying to restore balance.
Isn't that so wrong?
If you wish to abandon this creature, we will leave.
Well, no.
I don't want to abandon it.
But if we have to kill a bunch of Dark Elves to get there...
I remember a young Lodge whom until this very moment...
A trolley problem.
But an army of Draugr to save a wounded animal.
Yeah.
But these aren't undead Draugr.
They're elves.
Makes...
What's different?
We're not repeating the same mistakes.
Getting involved where we shouldn't.
It's fine.
It's fine, boy.
Animals are more important, right?
Isn't that your motto?
I thought that was your whole thing, boy.
Was it not?
Yeah.
Which way do I go now?
Oh, it's here.
It was just a secret chest.
But he only loves them and a certain amount, guys.
He never crosses that path.
Okay?
My boy will never.
I did not raise no, not that type of person.
He will never.
There it is.
I'm gonna be a sick-ass throw if it works.
Okay.
Okay, definitely not here.
Oh, no.
What would I do?
Alright, I'll just slowly walk backwards.
That's not it?
No, not from here.
And where from?
Oh, there.
From here.
I'd rather bang on.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Not in this room, boy.
Where am I supposed to hit this?
Maybe there?
Oh, it has to be this way.
A lot of you think of this.
You appreciate it.
Thank you.
You're like...
Yeah, from...
Oh, not from here.
Ooh, definitely not from here.
I can't reach that shit.
Where the fuck were you supposed to hit then?
Okay.
Yeah It has to be from here Right
No Where the fuck There's nothing for me to hit here
I'll be up here.
Oh my god, I have to be up here wouldn't I shouldn't I Look
there that bomb should help us out a bomb what oh that bob
okay i found the bob just why does it feel like no matter
what we do in alphan we wind up hurting dark elves did it
work to help the creature you heard i know that but i'm
usually the one who drags us around trying to rescue animals
why do you care so much yeah
i'm even confused okay Okay.
Nice, more crafting material.
That's good.
Alright, there we go.
Nice, we did it.
I was gonna say, why is...
Why is...
Why is Kratos, like, wanna help wanna help up this guy now?
He usually doesn't care.
Hey, he didn't care about the fucking baby bears!
How come he gets to pick and choose?
Yeah, I never forget.
I never forget.
Oh shit, I'm a little fucked up from that.
Hello?
Oh my god, I'm so fucked up.
Yeah, those baby bears were so cute.
Oh That's what that's where they're coming from
Well now he wants father-son bonding time this entire day is
father-son bonding time.
He's just trying to accept his furry side
He's like son I accept you
And what?
What is it?
Whoa!
It's a jellyfish!
It's not just in pain.
It's trying to sing.
Oh, it's a jellyfish.
It's the song of the sands.
You don't normally sing like this underground.
Is that what's causing the storm?
I, judging by all this hive matter weighing it down, it's
been trapped here for dozens of winters.
Don't worry, Lund.
We'll get you out.
What is that name?
Well, the last good thing you saw was Diner, so...
Oh, boy.
Well, I appreciate the attempt at humor.
Ha-ha!
That little brother is truly awful, won't play.
Embarrassing, really.
Oh, well, can't all be winners.
Huh?
What?
There has to be a way to get...
Okay, so I actually have to go down, I think?
There's gotta be a way to clear the...
Get a better angle.
I'm trying, boy.
What better...
Oh, there it is.
I'll say, what better angle can I get?
Oh, nice.
I got a better angle.
Gosh, I did it.
There we go.
Yeah, you're free now!
But it still can't get out.
...
is gone we can free it from the surface now from the surface
open the half cage on the surface i look up oh my oh i go
back up from here
simple man and thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you oh i'd hesitate to place full blame on our dark elf
friends maybe i'll cut but it's trapped in their hive stuff
yeah hive matter doesn't belong to the dark elves any more
and the light belongs to the light elves it's just another
of alpine's natural resources i think you just got caught up
the elves have used since the time of their ancestors i'm
gonna ask the boy first she's hiding under his bed thank you
the super chat thing thank you so by clearing out all of
this hive are we hurting dark elves you wish to leave the
creature enslaved now then let us free it we have pick or
choose who you who matters more the big ass jellyfish or one
big ass jellyfish or hundreds or thousands of dark elves
make your choice wisely boy that's a trolley problem i hate
the elves kill the elves
Okay, but where... what the fuck was the fucking thing?
Easeous trolley problem of my life.
I remember it was like, slow down.
I forgot to slow down.
That's the pause.
This is the spot.
We can cut the half-goof and lose here.
Oh, circle.
It's a cutscene cut.
Ah, Zona, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've been watching your content since TV.
Thanks for making me laugh like you did.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat, Zona.
Yay!
Good fucking courses flies.
I'm not even enjoying the content.
I've enjoyed my streams.
Oh, he did it!
Yeah, it's fine.
It's okay if a couple of dark elves died.
The storm's gone.
You don't have to do this kind of stuff.
stuff just to keep my mind off Ragnarok you know this was
not a distraction no then why are we really yeah have you
ever considered he just wants to spend time with you a lot
while he's still kind really we do not know what lies ahead
waiting for our approaches I wish to enjoy the time we have
left yes hi thank you my god bringing us out here i'm glad
we did this as am i oh my god that's so sweet he's like it's
like when your dad finally gives you a hug and be like i'm
proud of you son i don't know how that feels like but oh my
god i got this i love video games guys
finally i can i
Finally, I know what that feels like from my favorite video
games.
Okay.
Wait, he's still there?
Hello, jellyfish.
Hello.
Oh, he's just floating.
Finally.
Where is he going?
Bye.
A cheaper than therapy.
It's like, so that's how it feels.
Oh, it is.
I've got to remember to ask here about his travels to the
lands beyond the seas.
You wish to travel the world?
I don't know.
Maybe.
See new places.
Find out more about myself.
Is he going anywhere?
He's just vibing.
Is the little guy just vibing?
I guess he's just, he lives here now.
I don't understand.
I...
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, I'm close enough.
I was gonna say, why is it not long enough?
Okay.
There you go.
Where's the last one?
It's above average.
I asked my wife that every day.
Guys, it's above average.
That's what my wife tells me.
There's the last one.
Okay, come on.
It had a glowing.
Where the fuck is the last one?
It's just very cold.
Where is the fucking last one?
What the hell?
guys where is it oh my god okay it's up here how would you
put it up here who's gonna go up there and light it like
dark elves are you stupid that's not convenient who's gonna
fucking go up there and light your stupid shrine.
Oh, else I can fly.
Oh, Shemriya.
Oh, Chokey, they can fly.
Soldiers be fought in Svartalfi.
And help?
Yeah.
Spirits in Baha'u'llah until Ragnarok comes.
They were no spirits.
Oh, those Doki are fucking elves.
Activated his force as early as a standing army.
Perhaps something you could only do without any honor.
honest valkyries around to stand in his way
oh nice is there anything else to explore here that's worth
exploring or should I can I move on or that progress the
plot I mean I'm here what the fuck is that
oh I'm like it's like they live and I'm like, oh, here I
come.
There's a lot, but you come here later.
All right.
I'm in there's like open world L-time now.
Oh, shit.
Where's my HP?
Oh, no, that's bad.
This is bad.
I didn't even realize my HP was that bad.
Oh, my God.
Fucking course, there's the exploding goddamn salamanders
that's going in.
Okay, I should have to do this for the heals.
I gotta beat them up for some extra HP.
That's fine.
Oh shit.
Not fine.
Grab me!
Alright, I gotta grab this.
Oh wait, that's just regular loot.
I thought that was HP.
Oh my god, this is bad.
This is bad!
Oh my god, it's like me going invading your home was not a
good idea guys.
Who would have thought?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Let me fucking cook!
There you go.
That's five.
All right, that means I can kill him.
All right,
let's get him.
Oh my god, he baited me.
Fucker.
okay i'm locking in i'm locking in there you go fuck this
guy that's right fuck you in particular that's right boom oh
nice i got to read after my reward reading
All right, grab this loot.
I did free the jellyfish, though.
You're right.
Look, I'm making sure there's no invasive species here.
Who knows if this is their actual home?
You know?
What if this is the iguana situation, as always?
Oh, wait, that's Astro!
Wait!
Was that Astro Boy?
We're not Astro...
Astro... not Astro Boy Astro...
I meant...
You know what I mean?
Not Astro Boy.
Yeah, the cover here.
Yes, Astro Boy.
Astro Boy.
Now what?
My face is itchy.
I think my beard's coming in.
Is it?
Yeah.
On my jawline.
See?
It's growing.
All right, let's go.
Is it?
We go home.
Last note, just adopt.
It's not dirt.
Are you sure, boy?
Wait, there might be a little over here.
What is it?
Wait, there could be a little here.
Let me double check, boy.
Oh, shit.
It's just something dark out.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
It's coming.
Okay, you can help me though, right?
Alright, yeah, look!
Oh shit, no, it's the Lord.
It's the Lord, man.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
What?
Okay, that should have been a... that should have been a
parry though.
There we go.
That's fucking right, that parry was sick!
Oh shit, okay, I thought I could...
Alright, it's fine, it's fine.
I'll do this, and then grab that, and grab this, and then
grab this, and it's rage time!
That's fucking right!
Should have let me pick that up, bro!
Get rid of my anger in a healthy way!
Yeah!
Can't afford therapy!
Yeah.
Oh, and I get to read.
It is healthy if I can't afford it.
It's the healthiest thing I can afford, okay, guys?
These are my therapists.
I'm unstable and emotional.
And that's why I don't see her no more.
That bitch thinks she knows me.
all right let's see on this yeah all right now we can go
home
all right let's go home now there's way too much to explore
we'll do this another time but jokey he always say that is
there oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait including
asgar and the version grow up kept secret There's never
another tag.
Either way.
What difference did her life really make?
Rolled.
We will finish later.
How do I do this?
Oh, here.
I just have to run around.
Yay!
More shiny stuff.
I love shiny stuff.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta progress the plot.
This is a very long game.
Okay, now, now, now we go.
Now we go.
Now we go and progress the plot.
Oh my god, it sounds not okay there.
Oh my god, there's more loot.
I'm okay now.
It is you who builds it with skill.
Okay, now we progress the plot.
No more goofing around.
Well, I follow the yellow marker.
All right, here we go.
Atreus, I've been considering your question about whether
grower's deception made a difference.
I think of it this way.
When it comes to subverting prophecy, knowledge is power.
Because that means we don't have to leave mid-guide.
The finer details can lead you to tragically incorrect
interpretations.
Back in my homeland, I was privy to the operations of a
certain coven of heat witches who were keen on destabilizing
the government.
destabilizing the government and otherwise loyal man and fed
him a story of his own ascension to king let this wait stay
alert and you see siya is reacting to your reaction of the
dead poet reveal it's pretty funny to see you ask why he
didn't sound like ryan reynolds i don't even remember what i
said that game awards was like a fucking uh like it was a
blur to me do you guys know high guard technically is
releasing next week if i don't have it i don't know if we're
gonna see oh my god oh man yeah it was actually a fever
dream thank you for the super chat thank you thank you and
i'm i'm down i'm fucking gonna play high guard i just want
to know i what can we use for upgrades for abilities like
ruin wait oh yeah i Do that now?
Wait, what is this still?
Yeah, technically it's coming out like Uh, what is this?
The Immersion for a short duration The Immersion Rage and a
Bligh Stun to Nearby Enemies What do I want?
Which one's better?
Main or Ram?
But they like haven't said anything About it, so I'm like
confused Is it actually going to come out?
Like, I've heard nothing about the game since the Game
Awards announced it.
Which one's better, guys?
Mane or Graham?
I just think that's weird.
Like, are we going to get the game?
There's no trailer.
There's no nothing.
Nothing hyping it up.
I want to see the gameplay.
Gram is useful, but later.
So should I just upgrade?
I'll just try it.
Which one should I?
I like Gram.
All right, we'll grab Gram then.
And we'll upgrade it.
I'll upgrade Spider-Rage, too.
I'm going to upgrade all of it.
Oh, never mind.
Main for now?
Fuck, okay.
Then I'll upgrade this then.
All right.
I mean, I've fucking already upgraded a lot of my stuff so
yeah I think I did I not yeah no I wanted you guys said
later for grab
I still want to try it out even if it's dead on arrival like
I've made a tweet about it but I just think shooters in
general is just a dying genre right now like the only thing
game people are playing like we heard like apparently Call
of Duty is not doing so well now and not a lot of people
play battlefield too and and um i think like shooters is
just a dying genre in itself so there's not there hasn't
been a lot of like uh it has been a lot of like shooter
games that are releasing i guess like the only ones that
people are talking about are creators but it just hasn't
clicked for me i'm so because i guess like i've never been
an So, it's like, I haven't had art readers just click for
me.
I was playing with, like, some friends for art creators.
Just to...
Okay, we want to go to Sindri's, yeah.
And, like, I was just so bored.
I was honestly for me, it was just...
I was just bored because it's like...
It's like, yeah, you can play peaceful mode or you can play
like pvp mode but i i just don't think for me i just i just
hate i just hate that you lose everything too um quite sure
what the giants meant by any of it i i just hate like the
fact that there's a risk of losing everything and then and
then obviously the person who's more geared is gonna win
most likely win the fight too and you do want to go into the
fights and then peaceful mode gets tiring after a while too
yeah so for me it's just i just it's not for me speak with
you oh okay i forgot about that he existed yeah and in
peaceful mode like it gets tiring after a while i also need
a pee real quick i'll be right back
back i'm back uh uh nexi allen bite solid wb for rice jay
lecon mike star uh tom uh caguya captain x factor uh papa
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'll talk
more about later i had like a literal identity crisis this
morning because i was like or not this morning i'm not that
i don't wake up that early i
Who am I kidding?
What do you mean morning, Doki?
This afternoon.
That ain't me.
Anyway, I had like an identity crisis.
I'll talk more about it later.
But I had identity crisis this afternoon.
Because like, imagine I were talking being like, because
like, yeah, shooter.
Because like, you know, I'm good aim.
I'm good reflexes.
So it makes more sense if I like, you know, play more around
my niche and everything.
Because I felt like I was like, Back when I was in a
company, like for ENV tubers, I was like, like, I guess like
one of the first ENV tubers in a corpo that played like, um,
played like shooters at a high, high for English side off,
like obviously at a high level.
And so like that was a niche I established for myself back
then.
And then obviously I've been like straying away from it
because it's just as like like over the last like year or
two i've been slowly straying away from that i mean i still
do the rivals ring thing but um but it's like it's like um
there just hasn't been a lot of good shooter games coming
out recently and it's like so hard because like i don't want
to force my like i don't want to like um you know like force
myself to play valorant or because i'm sorry but
I feel like if I commit to it, I can get a high rank in
Valorant, I think.
If I commit to it, it's just more so if I like the game or
not.
Because if I like a game, I will get a high rank.
I will get a high rank on it.
It's like how, yeah.
Yeah, or it's like, what else?
What else?
And it's like, but like there's not, hasn't been in the
past.
We would get, like, I think when I was like in the company,
lot of shooter games because when we were in when we were in
the company we had um we had so many shooter games coming
out like always so it was like so easy and then like you
know apex was like super popular too so i could easily just
uh hop on to apex um if i wanted to i think apex is like one
of the easiest shooter collab games you can do for rivals
it's not the same it's not the same at the perfect balance
um where like there's downtime where you can have
conversations and then there's intense fight moments but
like if you look at rivals you look at overwatch you look at
valorant there's never really downtime there's more so it's
just always like you know you're just playing the game
you're just really just you're just playing yeah and then i
guess you have arc raiders where there is downtime but it's
an extraction shooter so like i've just i've never vibed
with extraction shooters because i just hate losing loot
because it's like yeah because i it makes me play more
carefully too because when i have good loot um i just like i
have to play super careful and then i have to like you know
um make sure like the fight is in my on my side as well and
in the fucking pve aspect because like that's a
like yeah the gear fear i can't i can't get rid of gear fear
i'm a loot goblin i've always been a loot goblin like what
about fortnite people are fucking pussies in fortnite yeah
the wild card i can't fucking oh man yeah the goddamn wild
card with the goddamn arc raiders and arc the arcs and the
raiders yeah and fortnite is super casual too yeah so i i've
been i was having an actual identity crisis with my manager
um this afternoon because i was like because i i don't know
maybe we can check out some older shooter games because like
um like the only shooter game i can think of to look forward
to too um
it's literally high guard that's coming out that's really
the only shooter i can think about that's coming out it's
literally high guard yeah i can't think of any other shooter
games that are coming out like that's good that we have to
look forward to speak if you are ever in need of my services
and i am not present i have installed these handy chimes for
you to notify me Simply throw your axe and strike the
chimes, and I will attend to your needs.
A lot of recent FPS games, even TPS games, haven't been,
like, really great so far.
I will say.
Boop.
A magnificent throw, Master Gives.
Truly a seasoned pro.
Yay!
You know how to reach me now.
Well, then, what else, friends?
What else?
I have a question.
Splendid!
I delight in offering my tutelage to the Inquisitive.
Over the ledge, by the gateway over there.
I noticed these dragons.
Oh, no, young master Atreus.
Those are leaned worms, the brood of Neathogue.
Neathogue?
That's the mother?
Correct.
She's also a vital piece of the Atrecelian circle of life,
as it were.
I tend the branches up here, while Neathogue chooses the
roots from below to prevent overgrowth.
A delicate balance.
So they're friendly?
Well, they're not nearly so affable as myself, but there's
no reason to expect hostilities.
so long as they're left in peace.
Nithog is a stern matriarch, as protective of her offspring
as she is determined to teach them proper discipline.
That sounds familiar.
Until we meet again.
I am already here.
Understand the great host.
For precisely those, though.
Perhaps there was some confusion.
This is for calling me out here, not for when I am here.
Do you just like hearing the sound of the chine?
I suppose they do sound very pretty.
Master Kratos, this feels very uncharacteristic of you, but
if you enjoy the pretty chine that much, I will allow you to
indulge.
Yes, you've been well-thrown.
Ah, the sound of the chine is not unmeanful at this
distance, so perhaps you could not?
already here as it were so i see you're deliberately
attempting to push me into some sort of emotional outburst
aren't you well i'm not so easily swayed my good man stop
with the stupid child oh dear i'm sorry i don't know
yay rage bait rage bait successful
yay won't you oh sure do we need a jingle keys for you thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you glad you're in a
better mood yes oh my next Mission, eat dinner.
Oh, he made the table!
Wait, which one?
Did he make this one or the other table?
Wait, I want to sit on the nicer table!
That's not fair!
I don't want to eat on the pretty table!
I never said that.
You're kind that way.
But your eyes say everything.
What's this?
Eat.
We were in the souls of Lake and we didn't even grab his
fourth soul.
Now he's gonna be blue forever.
Joki, what's wrong with being blue?
He is blue!
What do you mean?
What's wrong with being blue?
He is fucking blue!
You have to sit at the kid's table now.
Enjoy.
Enjoy, my friends.
Yeah.
We'll see about that.
Here you are.
A meal fit for a champion.
Whoa.
Don't touch my son.
Yes.
Of course.
Oh, because he's the champion.
He's going to kill Odin.
I'm not offended.
It's just a word.
The word didn't cloud your judgment.
Yeah, we can't have his ego.
You really don't think it means anything.
We can't boost his ego like that.
We got humble him.
everything we saw in Yodenheim what was it all for don't you
ever think about that every day purpose was to inspire you
to take foolishness but what if the Giants are counting on
me what Giants they're all dead boy you don't even press no
Giants but use the judgment of a man and not of a child but
what if Loki going to ironwood it's the only way that you're
not special boy he's like you're not special holy that's
fine that's too real oh my god that's too real
eat oh some people swear by it on almost a daily basis i
just don't understand why is there all this stuff about loki
and and the champion and iron would have none of it's real
he's just so ah he's gonna get her new bear i got the bear
in him
oh no that my racist dwarf is gonna say more bad things to
me
advice you've heard all day and possibly ever sleep that's
when all the troubles of your mind work themselves out sure
fine sleep sounds great I mean it I do too get out of here
already already already gone it's nice that we get his on
stuff.
I think the last game was mostly focused on Kratos.
But now we get to see like Arteus too.
We get to learn more about him.
It's in like a punk ass bitch no more.
He is too young to have opinions.
To have his free will.
Why is he lying on his bow?
He's gotta be protected.
Oh!
Young woman.
Oh no.
Okay, I was gonna be like, oh no, is it those types of
dreams?
That's why it's iron.
I'm sorry.
I'm 13.
My humor is that of a 13-year-old boy.
Oh, hey.
Oh, that's me.
That's me when God of War 1.
Or not 1.
In the last God of War.
got an elf on I wouldn't have felt so bad about killing so
many elves what's going on what is going on that a mask I
mean just knowing where gods makes me feel so much stronger
where am I oh no the voices over and over do something about
it or shut up or it little people's little problem we're
sick of hearing about little people's little problems
memories and not nice ones oh no that was the only way to
yonan what do you want let's go through my i don't
understand whatever oh no oh no whatever whatever oh no i'm
going through puberty right now my eggs my teenage eggs are
coming for me Oh, no, my angst die.
Will you stop?
My angst, please.
Whatever.
I'm going to hit my goth face now.
My emo face.
I got to get out of here.
First she came from you.
And so I said nothing.
Then she came for Smurrs.
Papa Smurr.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The cave.
The cave?
He should pay for what he said about mother.
But we're gods.
We can do whatever we want.
Well, his first kill.
Oh, shit!
Bro, when you get stabbed in a dream, you get stabbed in
real life.
Or is this just London?
This is a much better knife than mothers.
Please, stop!
Where am I?
Yeah, where is he?
Surreal music.
Oh, that's a bear.
Easy.
Oh, that's a wolf.
Okay, it was brown.
I don't know if I'm supposed to know
No, no, oh, no, he's having his furry awakening right now.
No, I say his turn back See you around the other side.
Oh, no.
Why is my controller making me walk towards the wolf?
This is I swear, guys, it's not me.
Where am I?
Can you understand me?
Two wolves.
Hi there.
So, where are we going?
There's two wolves inside me.
Got it.
Oh, a third wolf?
Oh my god, you know what's better than two wolves?
Kind of woke up here.
Three wolves.
this ironwood any idea how I got here oh I dreamt my way
here I mean I can speak furry I must have oh my he's in too
deep oh no oh no it's too late for him he can speak furry he
could speak words sent what's sent oh that might be fair
where you're smelling we sure we're here to meet you he what
ben you're still on me he's what he died several days he
died like i'll know a week or two ago you have two other
worlds are teas oh my gosh it's a whole pack it's a whole
fucking pack now what is that though the air here it's yeah
i don't know sweeter
trees there's six wolves now you tell me if you were gonna
eat me oh that's cute that's a joke right oh my god that's a
lot of wolves guys oh no mr broken bond thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you there's three wolves in me
i've never seen a forest like this before I don't know.
It's like a convention.
Is there a convention in town?
Wolfcon?
Through here?
There's wolf arc.
I told you it's the gateway drug.
It's the gateway furry.
Wait, that's me?
Did the wolves make this?
What the fuck?
I'm not finished with it yet.
Woman!
Young woman!
Yeah, we're kidding.
Dana's made from the bark of the ironwood trees.
They absorb the memories of the forest so that the paint
remembers too.
Oh, shit.
Memories of the past.
Who are you?
Of the future.
I'd hate to get blood on it.
So it is that type of tree.
I mean,
she was painting me, wasn't she?
What's wrong?
I've been waiting my whole life for this moment.
You look...
Weirder than I imagined.
Oh.
Is that supposed to me?
Sorry.
Um, was that mean?
I don't know.
Damn it.
I'm already messing this up.
It's just, you're the first person that I've talked to in a
very long time.
Is this going to be my first girlfriend?
Uh, thanks.
I feel like Arteus has not, like, encountered, like, women
his age, too.
i'm angoboda i'm angoboda have a lot of questions uh yeah
you'll get your answers soon enough oh thank god guys guys
he's safe well some of them guys he's safe i did raise my
boy right guys his first girlfriend is not a wolf when you
said you that's that's good that we take those we take those
right is that not You're a name?
No.
It is, my name.
It's not a horse or a wolf.
We did it.
We've succeeded in parenting.
Oh, there is hope.
He loves women.
Guys, human women.
Just remember, it's human women.
We did it.
All right.
Nice.
And then we get...
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
That's good.
We actually...
Let's grab...
Oh, a horn.
Okay, yeah.
We can charge it up.
That's good, actually.
She's...
She's human.
She has two legs and two arms.
And she's standing upright.
That's as human as it can get.
This weird fog.
I've heard the Uten Guard can be disorienting.
Still, you're safe here in the Ironwood.
also what in my what in my joyfriends like cj would be like
where the fuck did he go
so i thought ironwood wasn't a real place my stand my
standards for his future girlfriend was very low as long as
it's a human woman then like that's all that matters wait
what are you all dead
I see she's talking about how the other giants are dead now.
What's that?
It's big.
Whoa.
I thought giants weren't all supposed to be giant.
I mean, you're not giant.
So that's not a good comparison.
so what do you do here paint forage survive preserve what i
can but why wait for me yeah my destiny is to tell you yours
oh your life revolves around me you know that test where
like the test shows of like um is like the women uh like you
go like like what was it if two women can talk about um
stuff not related to men for x amount of towers Oh, yeah,
eventually.
She failed the test.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Yeah.
I got your back.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
We make such a good team.
Thank you So me the test doesn't count You're doing before
you came here surviving film.
Yeah, but like Loki could turn into lady Loki around here
wait It's me that's cool
Guys thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She's the mother of veneer and her I'll be annoying.
No, she's she's woman-shaped guys.
No, no, no, no, no, no, she is woman-shaped Maybe she's
also, we shared, maybe she's also a fellow furry, you know?
Maybe we just, uh, maybe, maybe Arteus and her just shared
similar interests.
But in the end, in the end, they chose each other.
So I, as Kratos, have succeeded in parenting.
Is that chainmail?
Women shaped so it doesn't count.
Kind of?
You Midgard Giants are strange.
They're dwarves, actually.
Still strange.
Wait.
I can't believe there are nightmares here too.
Yeah, that's crazy that they're here.
Why are they here?
They're not...
I should shoot something here.
Oh, this.
Can I shoot this?
Yes.
I was gonna say it's a fence.
Can I shoot the fence?
It's just something my father...
You know what?
Never mind.
I don't want to talk about my dad right now.
This is my angst phase.
I want... We're here to talk about me.
Hello?
Your entire purpose is to tell me my destiny.
So I don't want to talk about me.
That's okay, right?
Oh, my God.
Oh, I just...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think the OG missed Loki actually consumes her heart after
she gets pregnant and Loki gives birth to their children.
Oh, my...
I do not.
Holy shit.
Shit, that's, that's too, that's too kinky for even me,
Arteus.
That's just like, damn, bro.
It looks like you're going the right way.
Oh, these guys are wild in bed.
Holy shit.
That shit is wild, Loki.
No, that was like, oh my god.
That's too wild, bro.
I think she forgot to say the safe word.
He's like, that's how I want to go.
I'm great.
I met another living giant.
What's my destiny?
What?
Sorry.
I'm just really excited to talk to you.
Bro, no, he's fumbling it.
He's fumbling.
He hasn't talked to another.
He's been talking to animals for too long.
he's been talking to animals for too fucking long he doesn't
know how to talk to another person yeah i'm just in a
magical force that shouldn't exist talking to another giant
and she's yeah
we did it not a horse over here and she's wow thank god whoa
we held hands
thanks guess I'm still getting my hands our first hand our
first our first held hands my mother recorded her visions
their prophecy thought you might like to see them oh my god
wait is her mom oh oh my oh my Wait, is this Omai's
daughter?
Are they...
I know you have a lot of questions, but not this one.
I'm sorry.
Wait, what did he ask?
Oh my god, first hand holding.
What did he ask her?
I was too busy, smashy-smashy.
Oh, upper absent parents.
Okay, my parents, my one parent is also dead.
Loki!
Oh!
I've got it.
Tell me when.
Now!
Oh my god, we fight so well together too, guys.
Oh my god, we are practically made for each other, guys.
Look at that.
We, we fought, oh my god.
Look at us fighting.
Oh my god.
Oh, our chemistry is unmatched, guys.
Guys, look, Steve.
I've got this.
We have such good chemistry.
It's fate.
Look at that.
We're doing combos together.
Like a champion.
Thanks.
She knows.
You too.
So let's grab some extra.
Let's grab some extra dream money real quick.
We're like made for each other.
Guys, it's literally destiny.
I'm her.
I'm her destiny Oh, sure
Hang on yeah, we might have met 10 minutes ago, but I'm
literally her destiny She's been waiting for me
So in the end I'm practically her entire life Race you
across what oh my god i'm so i'm like i'm so head over heels
for her oh my god i'm in love i'm in love
whoa oh i'm ahead now that's right i'm faster come on girl
you know this was okay that's cheating what the Wait, that's
not fair.
She cheated.
She took a shortcut.
Well, you beat me.
I mean, I already knew that that.
Yeah, that's cheating.
Exactly.
See, she agrees with me.
Women.
Tackle worm.
I've seen this before.
Well, then you should know how to beat them.
Summon spirits.
It's usually not so lively right now.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
That's a bird.
You're just lucky.
Oh my god, look, we're laughing in the middle of the fight,
guys.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
Oh, we're finding.
Alright, we gotta grab this here.
all right nice jesus christ
okay i can do this boom okay come on i'll take it i'm taking
it
all right it's five i'll just hold on to this and then are
you serious it's really one hit
Look, I'm talking to my first woman ever.
It's not going to be perfect.
We can all fumble the bag a little bit.
Just a little bit.
This is her way of ensuring the legacy of our people would
live on.
Despite the ACR's best efforts.
It's okay.
It's just a small fumble.
Oh, wow.
Oh, you'll see plenty more button clamps today.
I hope so.
Oh, really?
Oh, I hope so, because that means I get to spend more time
with you, Malini.
Here.
Guys, I'm just trying to make it more immersive.
Oh, yeah.
You know what, Daniel magic?
Where do you think they learned it from?
Stop.
Here we are.
Do you live here?
This way.
How are you gross?
What?
it i'm just trying my best is this not flirting obviously i
should be able to read this that's that's that's like the
reading board
oh hey mount rushmore wait is this my shrine i've been
wanting to see it again oh is my lucky it's the yoda hat for
many giants there's is beauty in learning your path and
walking it.
Of course, others see the future and get messed up by it.
Ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
The future.
My destiny.
I've seen this before.
Where we scattered Mother's ashes.
It was on the wall.
Everything had happened already.
This is the way it's but this part was damaged oh that's us
it's in the bag huh that's me again wonder who he is oh
that's not me
wait dad wait my dad's gonna die it's not right no that
can't happen he's the god wait that's Thor no Oh, is that me
and Odin and Odin?
What?
What the prophecy said?
I was...
Ungar's not real.
None of this is real.
Oh, fuck no!
No.
I failed.
Calm down.
You're fine.
Jesus.
Hey.
Hey, breathe.
is very sad.
That's good.
See, it's okay.
Oh.
Let it go.
Come on back.
It's okay.
You're fine.
Sorry.
I don't know what happened.
Don't worry about it.
It happens to everyone.
She accepted him.
There's still hope.
Not the wolf part, but getting scared about your future.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
It says I serve Odin and my father dies.
There's just no way.
Look, this is the only way things turn out.
The sooner you accept that, the better.
Wait, but then the other prophecy says he dies.
Shit, that was mean to.
She accepted me.
There's still hope, guys.
Just forget about that now.
Yes, there's still hope.
It was just a one time.
It was one time.
You're a giant.
as long as it doesn't happen again you're clearly coming
into some powers that you don't understand yet come on let's
take a walk you can help me with something and I'll teach
you you know giant stuff giant stuff oh yeah cuz my mom died
before she could teach me giant stuff it's okay it's just it
was just one time
you know it happens you know this never happened before guys
i swear to god
all right it's okay everything is fine he let his wolf out i
thought i thought when i met her help with this What?
Is there just animals here?
What's this?
Here, follow me.
Where are we going?
We're gonna get some food, plant some seeds, my everyday
stuff.
But first, I want you to meet someone.
Oh, is it a crocodile?
Oh!
Meet Yala.
Hi, Yala.
That's cute.
Uh, nice to meet you.
Oh my god, wait, he's so big.
Perspective.
Perspective goes hard.
She's a big girl.
By controller, does she take me somewhere?
Come on up.
Good girl.
Ganga.
I just must have gone to Doki Bird's school of humbling in
the cute girls.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you want me to call you that instead?
No.
Loki's good.
Sure.
jam ha man I'm in she saw my furry side but I'm still in so
where did you say we were going we need to collect some
fruit if we follow the river we should find oh yeah I
controlled it we're quick journeying those flowers over
there silence I okay no that's what they're called they only
grow in yoten hunt and why my mother and i used to take naps
in them when my grandma and her fought it was one of the
only places she found peace why is your cat that's cool can
i go near this it's like a venus fly trap
i'm so in guys boy fumbles with doors like don't keep
fumbles with door chat will thank you thank you aha here's
one let's grab it who's it for wolves gotta eat don't they
never seen fruit like this before they're called green bulbs
oh yeah okay wait that's like that's good that's she's into
it she's into it it's good they taste terrible seems like
they work though it's good you might not been able to change
his destiny but that's okay excuse me she's into it like she
likes you yeah sure did you grab that one we're making food
he's talking she's talking about me right like what she said
wolves got to eat she's talking about me right there's no
other wolves in her life right guys I do oh my god no she
wasn't talking about me no I thought how is this you need
you and hurry to leave no i just gotta save my father's life
i thought it was okay we have time
can't believe it i see some fruit up there then we should be
up there too i can't believe it it's okay that means that
means that means it's fine wait i'm the best of both worlds
oh my gosh she laughed at my joke I'm so in let me help
that's when you know like I'm not funny but she still laughs
how dare she has friends after you let's go listen I know
we're out here having fun at all but maybe we should talk
about what you saw in the mural what I saw would never
happen I wouldn't join Odin if it caught the trauma if i
learned anything it's all about suppression that's what my
dad dad taught me things have a way of coming true one way
or another i learned from my father to close your heart to
it yeah see that's it see is that told him to suppress his
emotions and his feelings
can't reach it
where oh yeah that's a good that's well-trained yak you
know I may have thought about going to Asgard but I'd never
do it yeah my father wasn't helping me figure out my destiny
when Odin and I were alone he offered to teach me if you
were alone with Odin he could have easily killed you I mean
not that he's I'm not that weak.
I'm pretty strong.
You know that?
Actually, I'm pretty strong.
More fruit.
We don't need it, but we can grab it anyway.
How do you know when it's ripe?
My parents taught me.
It's a delicate guessing game.
So you can't be sure of everything that's going to happen
then?
Yeah, see?
I'm sure of the big stuff.
don't worry i'll make a path for her and now i win holy shit
girl your voice is beautiful
my goddess love getting these ingredients feeding your
animals you do this every day if i don't they'll die like a
lot for someone your age our age huh right one of the last
conversations i had with my father he said he was sorry he
couldn't protect me oh and i'd have to grow up so fast at
least you got an apology dads have a way with words huh oh
no i i saw a ledge there but like i thought this was the
other path no oh that must have been free items free loot
you know i was maybe i need you for something no maybe it's
not what i'm gonna go back maybe i'm tricking odin that's
true something you're good at i lied to my dad a couple
times no a massive deception green bulbs go here in this
bucket oh hey if i need a i missed the legendary eye or
something can i of course i've got supplies in my tool chest
over there by the way i left in the tool chest for you i'll
meet you over by yellow when you want to leave is it okay to
hang out around here as long as you want oh my god guys i'm
so weird she said and i'm recrafted by prophecy and
presented to one who will be the champion of their people
that's me no ego by the way oh my gosh she gave me gifts
guys wait which is better The Yonobo or the Talonbo?
New drip.
Which is better, chat?
Try both?
But which is better, though?
Oh, it's upgrade.
Oh, wait, my shit is upgradable?
Well, I'll get that shit in.
Magic, depends on your playstyle.
Okay.
Try this.
uh okay we gotta grab that you know upgrade this what do i
want i'll upgrade everything
and i'll see which one i want to change
uh uh okay i can't upgrade that yet
oh my god never oh my god oh my god I oh oh that's awkward
okay oh that's awkward I didn't realize I had a third okay
okay I didn't I that's okay it's fine I don't do I want it
I mean, stunning is always good, but I don't know what to
get rid of.
Maybe get rid of that.
Oh, I got it here.
Okay, thank God.
I was going to be like, oh, that's awkward.
I won't grab more archery upgrades.
Okay, thank God it was...
Okay, wait, maybe I can go back.
Okay, my yak is gone.
It's alright.
Never mind.
Maybe the yak will come back when he sees me over...
Okay, nope, he doesn't come back.
Oh my gosh, she invited me to her place.
Do you think, like, I'm in?
Hey, what's this one?
I painted that one with grandmother.
Wasn't as good back then.
I think it's beautiful.
It's very beautiful.
Oh, this is where I came from, right?
Yeah.
What's next?
Well, now's when I usually harvest the V-tube.
roots i mix with them i mean unless you still want to leave
no i can stay wait i want to stay oh my god i can go back
i'm gonna grab loot first give me a sec the loot goblin in
me i must go back
oh my god we got an artist oh my god nice okay Luda is much
more important, guys.
Guys, what if it's the legendary bow?
That will help me beat the game.
That one shots everybody, guys.
It won't let me back in.
The game was like, turn around right now.
But the legendary bow!
Mr. Broken Bot.
the super chat thank you thank you yeah what if it lost a
super secret boss the first girl the boy met around his age
immediately folded this is why Kratos is disappointed thank
you with a super chat oh wait hey I don't read I don't know
what the lore behind that what's the lore and Gubauda
earlier you said the Uden guard can be disoriented see okay
but what is it Amir the first of our people he died a long
time ago right Odin killed him yes Odin destroyed everything
that remained of him saved for one thing his dreams Odin
couldn't touch those if he tried and they are ours why is
she going this way why did she go um hello okay
I was gonna say that broke that broke her I would, I was, I
was like, oh no, oh no.
I broke it.
All right, here you go.
All right, we go this way.
I paint too.
Well, I draw.
Oh my God, we share the same hobbies.
All kinds of things.
Monsters, artifacts, anything father and I encounter on our
journeys.
Oh, is your father an artist too?
No.
What?
Okay.
And he's like, ha ha, no.
Easy, girl.
You've got this.
Do you have any animals that could maybe go faster?
No, offense, Yalla.
Of course I do.
They just can't carry both of us.
This is much easier.
I'm not that heavy.
It's just all pure muscle.
Yeah, you won't feel it?
You won't feel my biceps, girl?
Um.
Um, it's just all muscle.
I'm big-boned.
Chill, dokey.
Why are you such?
I'm a B!
I'm method acting.
I'm trying to be immersive.
You won't need that.
The root's not pretty easily.
there just take a little off a good twist ought to do it see
oh yeah you saw that exactly almost loud we're coming we're
coming there's more roots this way i told you so how quick i
ripped those roots girl go see me do it again he really
doesn't like me huh she does it's just apart from me Oh,
shit.
That'll be fine.
Oh, he was not fine.
Oh, shit.
Don't have to worry about concussions.
I'm a champion.
I'm a god.
Loki, show me the wolf.
Oh.
Okay.
That is great.
Right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, on the first day, she's a keeper.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I gotta let the beast out.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you don't want it!
Oh shit, I accidentally did it.
I had to show...
My girl wanted to see the wolf.
Give my girl what she wants.
Gotta press the ladies, guys.
She asked for it!
There you go.
All right, here we go.
All right, yeah.
Yeah, like I'm not in control.
I show her the I show her the alpha inside me On the first
date too You're freaky, freaky.
Oh, back to roots.
Well, at least there's some roots down here.
Grab them while we look- It's wolf in time.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's your answer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I took you in time.
Pay you sing animals.
Run for room five.
Oh, shit.
That's a big boy.
Fuck it.
Oh, wait.
I almost got it.
That's Afri.
It's all right.
I got the stag in me now, though.
Oh my god, the stag in me.
There you go.
Oh!
Nice.
Try and charge this up.
charge this up too.
I've got you.
Oh, shit.
She got me, though.
Okay.
Maybe I don't pull up roots for a little bit.
It wasn't you.
Hey, looks like they opened up a path over there.
Oh, nice.
Let's catch up with Yala before more of them show up.
Yeah, I hope Yala's okay.
Animal.
Bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada.
We're practically made.
You're okay.
But what about you, Loki?
What do you feel when you change?
Just anger.
Part of you unleashed the wolf with that anger.
Maybe you just need to find the part that will guide it.
How?
You can fight with all sorts of emotion in your heart, not
just rage.
If rage lets it out, another might help you.
Stay you.
Oh my god, there are two wolves inside me.
You enjoyed that, didn't you?
Oh my god, one wolf is angry.
The other wolf is in control.
Home again.
Yeah.
I made it.
Let's drop off these roots in the bucket up on the left
here.
Then, I've got one last thing to show you.
Oh.
You okay?
Yeah, just...
We should head back toward the water.
Oh?
This way.
Is it alright if we stick around longer?
Might want to, you know, repair some stuff.
Yes.
Oh?
Oh.
Repair stuff.
I guess from here?
Is there anything in here that I need to look at?
I mean, everything's fine.
Oh, everything seems fine.
Oh, I just wanted to spend...
Yeah, oh, we're so smooth.
Yeah.
Repair.
Yeah, yeah, sure, boy.
You want to repair some stuff, right?
Alright.
Let's go.
Are there any animals you can turn into?
Not yet.
But for you, that might be a god thing and not a giant
thing.
Oh.
Thanks for rubbing it in, though.
Sorry.
Joking.
Through the tunnel on the right, y'all.
That's where we're headed.
Oh, okay.
I'm Yala.
Head of end.
Oh, la.
Oh.
I really like that spell.
That's so cool.
Maybe that's why I couldn't sense any other giants when
Father and I visited.
Wait, there's loot.
Oh, my gosh.
She's perfect.
She knows magic.
I know magic.
She's okay.
She likes it when I unleash the beast.
We're made for each other.
So, what's that soul in your knife?
The what?
There's a soul inside your knife.
It's Fenier!
No.
Who's soul?
You know, maybe you should keep it where it is until you
figure that out.
Oh!
I don't just...
Is Fenier gonna help me control my wolf?
How the fuck do I get that?
Y'all can swim around and meet us on the other side.
Okay, but I want to get this.
How the fuck do I get that?
Oh, I know how.
Watch this.
I figured it out.
This puzzle is no match for me.
I'm smart.
Watch this.
Ha ha ha.
Just drop from that clam too.
Want to check it out?
Oh my god, he's going to be the Mufasa.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure Venya's going to teach me out of
control my wolf oh nice we actually needed a beast bone
all right where do we go okay she is going left which means
i can go
left what you're doing what you're doing clears my mind i
try to see how many bounces i can get oh you're like
skipping stones looks easy enough
yo oh apparently not as easy a little help no i i think i
got it and you're like it's it's the rock guys it's the rock
we all know when you're skipping stones the rock has to be
the perfect shape for it because if it's two and it's not
like if it's not like sharp then it can't skip and He
purposely gave me a shitty rock.
I might need a little help.
You'll get it.
Throw a flatter.
It's all about timing.
When you release the rock.
Yeah, the rock is the most important factor.
Oh shit!
Bring the wolf Loki, but under your control.
I don't have to.
Oh shit.
I mean, he's gonna get them.
Alright.
I am in control.
I am in control!
Guys, I'm controlling him!
I am so in control!
Alright, nice.
Alright, there you go.
So much control!
Alright, let's get rid of this gap.
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Okay, that guy is a big boy.
There you go.
I'll use my stag.
Boom!
There you go.
Oh, that's a lot of damage.
Ready.
That didn't count, by the way.
My last throw.
Oh, it counts.
A troger came out of the water.
Yeah, that's not fair.
What?
I never make any excuses.
All right.
Watch this.
Hold.
Release.
Oh, did she saw that?
Did she saw that?
Do you think she saw that?
Oh, and another one!
You want to release the rock earlier.
There we go.
You got to release it earlier.
What do you mean?
Okay, you fucking liar.
There we go.
Nice throw.
Yeah!
Look, she complimented me.
Almost there.
Okay, what the fuck do you mean?
Wow.
Oh, shit.
I did it.
See?
She saw it, guys.
She saw it.
I don't like the five of it being Fenrir.
So, raw.
This level three five troll is too tough.
I'm sorry.
I must release the beast and go full Fenrir mo.
Thank you for the super chat about you.
Thank you.
Where are we going now?
I have something.
Yes, to unleash the beast.
Gift, I guess.
Should I be scared?
I'll get there.
I don't have anything for you.
Oh, here.
That means for next time.
That means I have to...
Bro, bro.
Bro, Arteus, stupid.
That means next time.
That gives you an excuse to come back next time so you can
give her something, Arteus.
God, think with your brain.
Think, Arteus.
Think.
You don't have anything now, which means you can come back
and give her something later.
Because it's so smart.
I know.
Ask you something.
Of course.
Are you...
Are we...
The only giants left?
Oh, no.
Sort of.
It's complicated.
Wait, what?
I want to know.
It'll be much easier to just show up.
What about my prophecy then?
Wait.
If it is true...
We gotta continue the bloodline.
What do you think I should do?
Doesn't matter.
There's no changing where you end up.
You can try whatever you want to avoid it, but it'll happen
anyway.
You're telling me nobody has ever changed their fate?
Ever?
I mean, sure, maybe some details change, but the endpoint
remains the same.
It's better to walk your path than to struggle against it.
But then my papa dies.
I don't like that.
Wait, because, like, um...
Because Kratos saw that he was going to die anyway.
So that's why he wanted to spend more time with his son.
Oh, because he knows.
He knows his fate.
What's that?
A lift.
We'll have to leave Yala for a bit.
That's why he wanted to do the little side quest.
There's some gift.
doesn't seem like something you're excited about just means
we're coming up to the end what does that mean you'll
understand once we get there no does that mean no you're
real you won't disappear after it right your purpose can
even though your whole destiny wants to tell me this we can
still see each other right
now that's why he's trying to teach time to hold up my end
of the prophecy that's why he's trying to teach like him
everything before he goes
thousand i got another rune what is this oh i don't need
that that means i can upgrade okay yeah we gotta get that
okay oh that's why he's so harsh on him because he he's
trying and teach him as many lessons as he could before it's
too late.
Oh,
shit.
Yeah, that guy's dead, dead.
Oh, my gosh.
She's got my back.
Look at that.
She's already... Oh, my god.
Wait.
Goodbye.
Yeah, do you think that's...
Oh, wait.
I was like, is that overkill?
He's like, I live.
Like, fuck the wild, like.
Only I shall be the last bird.
Oh my gosh, she could like crush me right now with that
rock.
She could have easily killed me right there.
Now we know she's not lying.
She loves me for me.
That's good.
Now we know.
She's not here to actually kill me.
Oh,
yeah, you're right.
I quite lifted it myself, you know?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, I could have done that myself.
Or is it?
Oh.
Let's see.
Where is the...
Oh, shit!
I was like, where...
Oh, my God.
He's right above me, isn't he?
A fucking chorus.
I was like, what the fuck is the...
sound effects that I'm hearing.
I was so confused.
Wait, there's something.
I can go up here.
But how?
Oh, whatever.
I don't care that much.
Get you a girl that doesn't try to kill you.
We're coming up on the valley of the fallen.
What happened to them?
They were tired of living in fear of asking.
guard.
So they've hid.
That makes sense.
That's how the corpses to confuse Odin.
Should he ever find a way into Jotunheim?
Where'd they hide?
Yeah.
Wait, how did they all die?
If Odin never found him, how the fuck did they all die?
I got it.
He's like, yeah, I'm a strong independent woman.
Oh.
That's beautiful.
And his first date is going really well.
Oh, more marbles.
Wait, you've seen these before?
Not these, but I found a few in Midgard.
Where?
Huh?
Inside your mother's murals.
What?
What's that?
There's more out there.
Huh?
What are they?
just look
words Fiatzi
Crowther Hey careful Aura
Giants These belong to the Giants These are the Giants Huh?
they had a choice look Morty I turned myself into a marble
they could stay sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry waiting for Odin
to find a way in to slaughter them or they could hide my
father helped whisper their souls into these oh and before
he died He passed him on to me.
It's within these.
We got him Pokeballs.
Yeah.
He found a piece.
Oh, so like they magic themselves into marbles.
That's fucked that she stretched this solo.
Wait, are we turning her into a marble?
My girlfriend's gonna turn into a marble!
That's rough.
Are you sure?
Well, that's what my mother saw.
You're supposed to know what to do with them when the time
comes.
And when is that?
I don't know.
Let's head back.
Why is it my responsibility?
This is a lot of responsibility.
It is.
And it's all yours.
Hey.
you okay so i can summon the giant army yeah no i'm just i'm
done i guess okay at least yeah you those my part in all
this is okay she's not gonna turn herself into a marvel
marvel to think guy we could fight odin together no i was
supposed to fight alongside you i wouldn't disappear from
your damn mural halfway through huh i understand but you
said it doesn't we don't like some things change we
shouldn't break up the set don't you think
let's keep
walking I can't believe she broke up with me on our first
date huh the tallest peak in the realms that's beautiful the
only other time I was in Yodan Han I was there with my
father you know the Giants fingers I spread my mom's ashes
there Feels like ages ago.
Hey, just because of some dumb mural.
Yeah.
Your story doesn't have to be over.
I know.
I mean, I have plans.
Am I in those plans?
It's over as far as the giants are concerned.
So what's that make me?
A friend?
Maybe more?
Wait, so then like the one we found in Midgard, the other
giants figured out how to also put their souls into marbles.
Feel what?
Help me with this.
We should get back to Yala.
Something feels off.
I'm friends, okay.
I'm just trying to see what we are, you know?
And then she could be like, oh, we can be more than friends,
you know?
Like, I was just thinking she would say that.
Is that what...
Is that like what...
Hey, Voda, could you help?
Is she okay?
Huh?
Oh What's going on What It's okay.
I can handle it.
Oh, don't like get down wrong like I'm a wolf.
Whoa, fall It's okay.
I'll let the wolf inside let the wolf out beast mode.
Oh shit wolf god wolf god Wolf god wolf god Wolf god that
was my whole strat Wolf unfortunately god
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
That's a big-ass wolf, though.
Okay, that's good.
That's a good parry.
Nice.
Parry!
Get parried!
Oh, shit.
I can't parry that, but that's fine.
There we go.
Hey, Gubota.
Where'd you go?
Let the wolf out.
hello hello okay yeah she was fine sorry about that so yeah
why didn't she lift the rock it's marbles they're all that
remains of the giants not all of them some are just missing
but where could they be nowhere in the nine realms as far as
anyone can tell because odin wants to kill all the giants so
that the prophecy doesn't go foretoed so then that means i'm
gonna bring the out of the marbles like a pokeball I'm like
oh giants go so I can actually so I can like make like bring
the prophecy to life see guys I can retain information I
follow through because I need the giants for the prophecy
far up past those rocks there's a sinkhole that's where
we're headed we should something on your mind nobody
believed this place was real they're gonna be so surprised
Loki you can't tell anyone about Ironwood not even your
father the biggest thing keeping this place safe is that
Odin's not I did it my wards can keep the wildlife at bay
but if Asgard ever came looking I get it I'm sorry I won't
tell anyone they want to hear it because he was supposed to
lead the army of giants see see i remember i remember the
prophecy because it's my destiny i never forget my destiny
see guys new we have company oh it's a phoenix fox Whoa, hi.
Very calm down.
Here's another one.
So is Irpa like the pack leader?
No, that'd be note.
She's one of the elders.
Yeah, look.
Don't shoot it.
What if it's, what if he's delicious?
Lots of creatures in it.
to get a lot of supplies for paint down there yeah we should
run them out your paint supplies are important if that's
what you want to do uh sure why not lean back all right down
i go
Wee!
A thousand calories minimum.
Our two is thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I...
It's a gift.
Aww.
But, uh...
Ah!
Hang on.
We're looking for wretch nests.
Those will give me the supplies I need, so keep an eye out.
I'm okay.
I showed her my wolf.
And that's...
And it's already over.
What's the point?
What's the point of showing her the wolf inside me?
If she won't even accept my flower.
It's over.
I knew it!
They're all the same.
The first woman I met.
We're literally the last remaining giants.
Wretches.
A nest of them.
They're everywhere down here.
Can't.
Literally.
There were the only two.
Like, I was part of her destiny.
And she already.
She already doesn't want me to.
What?
I'm out and grab what I need from them.
Let's do it.
If you leave, I'll light the torches.
What's the point?
Where do I lead?
I got this one.
Like this one?
Oh wait, look.
Like, what's the point?
Stop doing.
I'm so sad.
i thought i thought we were supposed to be like our destiny
was supposed to imply you know
like this where do i go
oh i knew i know you ain't real there are two wolves inside
me and it hurt
My first Breakup I'm so I'm so sad My first Breakup Is that
everyone?
Oh my god Oh my god that was not all of them
What the fuck is the next?
A little bit of this, a little bit of that.
Oh my god, it's above me.
It was above me.
I was like, where the fuck is it?
Now to find the rest.
Star Ace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
His first heartbreak.
I'm sorry, Arteus.
It's kind of funky.
We have to be so vulnerable.
Okay, obviously we can't go there.
I'm always worried I'm like missing loot.
Tokey has such negative risk.
She needs prophecy to get a woman.
It doesn't even work.
She was destined to meet me and she still doesn't want to be
with me.
it's so hard not to get lost in here right yeah we're fine
what the fuck where the fuck did she fucking go oh shit how
you doing champ okay like i was like where the fuck that
come from all right this way i knew it i know you ain't real
there you go left or i was left i think there's like okay oh
god flashbang okay let's use this just because i can That's
right.
I knew it!
I knew you weren't real!
But where did you go?
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
You should visit Midgard.
Yeah, this is a dead end.
This way?
God, I'm so lost.
These tunnels are fucking hard to navigate.
I swear, this place didn't I used to be so...
Where am I?
Okay, I looped.
Wait, I didn't.
Oh, I looped.
Okay, it's this way.
And then it's this way.
It's my...
I'm in a situation, shit.
I don't know yet.
Maybe, like, later on, like, you know...
These nests aren't just out here.
Damn it.
Got it.
Where's the nest?
Can't you guys just leave us alone?
Yeah!
Okay, I've done a shortcut.
Where the fuck is their goddamn nest?
Oh, it's up there.
Alright, there you go.
I was like, where is it?
Oh my gosh, it's not even dead yet.
There you go.
Shouldn't be many left.
one more nest all right this way wait is it this way I just
want to be sure there's nothing I'm missing here nope all
right go through this bridge then I have an idea what if you
came with me Midgard the other realms anywhere I'm not
desperate or anything yeah my animals need me but Yeah, but
we can bring the animals over.
It's okay.
The animals can come with us.
I think there's another one nearby.
I got this one.
Oh, here.
Where did he come from?
Oh.
I've been there.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's here.
There it is.
It's almost down.
Oh my god, there's like one tiny baby that came out of it.
I think that's all of them.
Yeah!
Feeling any better?
A bit.
Let's head back.
I knew it.
I knew this would take me to the chest.
Yeah!
Loot loot time loot loot Or you could live with her that's
true that is true that is true What the fuck where did he
come from?
That's it boom
Easy yeah you try to you try to surprise me I'm supposed to
pick one my if you have more than one no i got this um blue
wait maybe green yellow is also so good yellow is good i
forget about red all right um where do i go i i here oh here
I was gonna say, like, how do I get out of here?
Um, is he supposed to be here?
He was bound to be mad.
We destroyed their nest.
All right, that's fine.
Wolf time.
Wolf time!
Beast mode!
Boom!
Okay, that did nothing.
That beast mode did nothing, guys.
Holy shit!
Bro, okay, I don't know.
He is so strong.
It is so strong.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Okay.
We dodged it.
Oh, we dodged it.
There we go.
He's dead.
Holy shit.
That was so much fucking damage.
Yeah.
You?
ready to be out of here i felt like he could like hit kill
me in four shots
let's head home you know learning my destiny would change
something but i'm still just me was it like that for you
you're always still going to be you loki it's about coming
to terms with it and you've come to terms with it i thought
so back the way we came now head around the sinkhole it'll
be be quicker where do we go and home through the marshes
where's that oh this way
all right nice oh i meant to ask you your mother had visions
can all giants tell the future some and dreams hey yeah i
dreamt of thor a while ago thor came true too he showed up
at my house he did sounds kind of like a nightmare yeah yeah
it's pretty freaky it's pretty scary you almost killed my
dad because we sort of killed his sons but you know they
were pretty dead are they dangerous that's adorable kind of
nice yeah yeah at least the fireflies are alive here yeah I
wasn't scared or thing though like i think i could take him
in the fight she called me adorable perfect oh my god we're
back in
oh oh wow oh it's beautiful yeah he was so scared of me he
ran away yeah things have been weird in a lot of ways but
i'm glad you came here me too
Are we...
Can I...
I was just like, so, uh, what are we?
I just, yeah.
That's it?
That's...
No, I wanna...
Oh, it has?
So now that I know how to get back here, I could come back
anytime I want it, right?
When?
I don't know.
There's no way I missed the prompt there is yeah, sure that
there was a quick dive event There's no way there's no way
there is no way I waited.
I waited.
I was like so what are we I?
No I
waited too.
I was so patient.
I was like I even waited.
I was like, surely something else, like, oh, maybe nothing
happens.
I guess I leave now.
Ah!
I fumbled it.
Oh, generational fumbled.
Good girl.
You can do it, Yolo.
I believe in you.
I can't believe it.
I even waited.
Oh.
No matter what game, I always fumble it.
Are your paintings?
They're really good.
Are you trying to cheer me up?
Yeah.
Is it working?
Ask me again and...
Oh!
No damn time.
No!
What the?
Shut up.
late to wine now now
damn it who was that why was that she um no
what the who the is this guy
what's wrong with it boy he's blind i can't if you know
anything There's nothing too few.
He's soulless.
Ralu whispered it, soul away.
You
know where she lives?
What are you gonna do?
I've buried enough wolves this winter.
Follow me.
Our cherries, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Oh!
Another fruit.
Who?
Oomsy.
One of the elk who comes around here.
a picky eater but you can't afford to be picky when there is
a food left oh man
he's blood for you don't have a soul you become i got that
live what that's a what
it's like gingers they have no soul
become blue.
Does that mean blind people have no souls?
It doesn't mean you have what her there's a gorilla on the
loose.
It's just like gingers.
Is that what she's implying?
Another one?
Where?
What the fuck are these people oh shit okay that's it
there's too many people i gotta use this there's way too
many all right nice at least they explode each other run
into gryla please don't do anything drastic why she's my
grandmother she's my grandmother when she learned my father
wouldn't do anything to avert his fate she changed or she's
her oh so she's not the only giants left
why would she take the souls away looks like we'll need to
find a way through
i didn't fumble then oh my god okay that's good that's good
i got okay that's good i didn't fumble it oh my god thank
god there was no quick diamond okay i'm so happy that means
there's a doctor's chance you almost got me saved the
relationship is still salvageable
oh this is my yellow paint he's my yellow paint that's why
he's here he's like
so you're telling me there's still a chat Oh my god, not him
Nice, okay, that was good timing for me And I also have my
girlfriend to do this too
There you go That's right Watched, oh no no no no I do this
And then I'll get the sag out Oh, that's good It's almost
dead Okay, now it's just a little guys that I'm fine with
I'm fine with it.
It's just a little guys now
That's fine let them explode.
I don't need a dwarf finisher Actually, I do.
Yeah
Did a lot of giants live here over time you want to know
about your mother she lived this entire life before she had
me But I don't know anything about it How did she even meet
Kratos?
Your mother left the path of the giants way before I was
born.
Alright, nice.
Oh nice, more free stuff.
Fighting?
I mean, he is the god of war.
In a battle?
This is Grel's home.
No lights.
She may still be checking her traps, but she might have more
animals inside.
We have to be quick.
Violence.
Ah.
The perfect way.
Kratos was like, John, woman.
There's another way in.
Up there.
We'll have to figure out how to get to it.
Puzzle time.
Oh, there it is.
Never mind.
Not really a puzzle.
White paint time.
Maybe there's a way up on the other side, but I won't be
able to get across.
It's not here?
Okay.
Is there something I can shoot from here?
Oh, I don't fucking know.
I'm looking.
I'm looking...
Oh my god, it's tiny green shit.
No.
It was like the faintest green I've ever seen.
So, Gryla, what does she need animal souls for anyway?
She can live moments from their lives.
What the fuck?
Bro, she's micro-dosing.
Oh, no.
But it's not real.
We gotta take her to rehab.
Oh, no.
Your grandma's an addict.
She's chasing the hot.
Oh, God.
Take your granny to rehab.
Oh, shit.
She won't hear this, right?
Ryl is still out.
Wow.
The things are so big.
Oh, my God.
Whoa.
There's a door to the cellar over here.
truly is a giant woman.
Are they here?
That's just lore stuff.
I assume?
The key's already in the log.
Just gotta turn it.
Eh.
Jesus.
Wait, does that mean she's gonna grow that big too?
If her grandma was was this big.
I mean, she has to be this big.
Just haven't hit a growth spurt yet.
Makes sense.
Oh, I can't go back.
Well, I hope I got all the loot there.
Holy shit.
Even this is like there's a big ass staircase.
I definitely like playing Arteus more than Kratos.
I'm breathing near the back of the cellar.
Me too.
I'm not hearing their voice.
I just... I think the bow...
I like the bow mechanic a lot more.
For sure.
Yeah.
Yes, he has pew pew.
And yeah?
I need to find a way back there.
Yeah.
I like pew pew.
What can I say?
Pew pew is fun.
Pew pew is life.
Alright, nice.
we got money.
Oh, it has that money too.
This is giant money.
The only Kratos had a gun.
In this game would be perfect.
Oh, it's a snake.
Oh.
She took it, soul.
There's not much more we can do.
Can we not like bring, give him the soul back?
Oh.
Hold this.
What are you?
You didn't have a least favorite giant.
Did you?
What the fuck?
Never mind.
I'm gonna put a s- No.
Your mother said I'd know what to do with this.
Eventually.
I just gave them to you.
I know.
He's like, we're back.
my legs right imagine you guys just woke up you're like what
the fuck is my legs are you sure
it's who did you hate the most deter the turn of the giant
snake it's messed up i don't know man i don't with that i
don't know how to do this part my arms and legs.
I don't know, man.
I know you love animals, but not everyone loves animals.
Beck yeah.
Oh, is this the world serpent?
Oh, so they gave birth to the world serpent.
You're like, where'd my legs and arms go?
That's it?
You got turned into a giant snake and where's it going?
Does that even work?
I don't know.
We're safe.
I was like, bro, you got turned into a giant snake.
Like, that's how you're gonna react.
But you're giving up already?
They're your responsibility.
It's not that.
And he's out.
It's not.
I just think they're better off with you.
Bro, he's just gonna put it in random animals.
I guess I'm a snake now.
Are you certain?
Call me, Atreus.
Okay.
Yeah, but he used to be a giant.
It's his whole.
Oh.
Oh my god, he just returned her gift.
Let's get back.
That's fucking crazy.
I'm sorry.
I just...
We'll have to get out the same way.
we came in she can't know we were here we better put that
cut back when we get to it that's fucking crazy i just
fucking put a giant soul in a snake and then that's it i
guess that's it that's crazy that's like and then he just
slithered away slither slither and he's slither like he's
just like he's like what that i that's just that's just
fucking weird
like the last thing he remembers is being turned into a
fucking marble and then he wakes up and now he's a snake and
he just accepts that like i i don't know like he just
accepts that he last thing remembers marble now he's snake
and he's fine with that he always wanted to be snake it's
what the is going on solid snake thank you hood is super
chat thank you thank you
he's just a chill guy hey help me with this it's heavier
than it looks
hide me enough whining oh i can't even remember in a moment
oh no stop her
we're just going to kill him no because we are going to stop
her i've avoided this for too long she's not well
no you should be thanking me as a soul to anybody it's just
a vessel for pain i damn near envy you okay the cauldron
without it she'll have no use for the souls i'll distract
her you free the wolf then we break the cauldron you sure no
but we can't hide forever go no but what if she It takes our
soul.
I told you, never to come back here.
That's right, look at me.
There's so many things I've forgotten, and you've refused to
be one of them.
It doesn't have to be this way.
If Ragnarok is coming, wouldn't you rather face it together?
What does destiny ever do for anybody?
What does your mom do with your father's destiny tonight?
Oh.
I won't give up on you.
Oh!
you brought a friend no no oh shit oh fuck oh I did not
expect to meet my family though your family so soon yeah oh
I didn't know there was I didn't know I couldn't listen to
more dialogue through here I wanted to free the wall I
wanted to free him I felt so bad I didn't want I'm gonna
hear him cry!
Oh my god!
Do you think she likes me?
Do you think we could get home?
She wants to see me again?
You know, I mean, like, first impression really matters,
and, you know, I want to be able to be good with your
in-laws.
God had destroyed that cauldron.
Can you swing across?
Yeah, I sure...
I sure can.
you hiding oh shit oh shit wait from that okay what the fuck
do i
oh shit having a bit of fun before your father broke don't
talk about my father oh she knows the prophecy too oh my god
she's actually wait she's fucking dropping big souls that's
messed up you'll do well is only stable shut up shut the
fuck don't talk to my father like that you'll forget all
about your old one yeah okay
bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam all right there you
go
It's okay.
They're not your souls But it's not okay Oh my god, what do
you mean?
I won't get oh my god.
It's over.
I didn't realize I could do that I'm ashamed.
We're even related girl.
You don't need that.
Oh shit
That's fucked Okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
She's spilling all the sauce!
You will not touch my carbon!
That's so fun!
Okay.
Oh shit.
I gotta go up.
Hot ground.
That's okay.
I got high ground.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Me and my girlfriend working together beat up a grandma.
It's so romantic.
I got nothing to you.
It's so romantic, guys!
Okay, you know I was not paying attention to that.
I have auto-aim.
Okay, she is, like, not letting me see anything.
She's not letting me get close to her at all.
This is all I've got!
back here okay oh i'm so focused right now what the do you
mean you're you're literally eating sauce what did i you're
like eating her pet sauce
yeah Are you serious?
That hits me?
I'm near to get closer.
Come on, get a little closer.
Oh, wait, that should hit, right?
Are you serious?
That doesn't hit?
Oh, my God.
That's so close.
Stay food.
I'm up, I'm up!
Oh god, oh god!
Oh god!
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I have to be so locked in!
Oh, fuck!
Guys, did you think I was really locked in?
Oh my god, god damn it.
I messed up.
Okay, that has to be close enough, right?
Nice.
Oh, wait!
Yeah!
Okay, okay, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm so alive.
And circle!
It's like she's a giant or something!
Let's go!
Yes!
That's right, Grandma.
This is an intervention and you have a problem.
I saved you.
I should have thrown you to the woods right after I pulled
you out of your mother.
I don't mean that.
Get out.
I just...
Get out!
No.
Also, I hope the mom was just as big as her.
Oh my gosh, she must have been a really fucking tiny babe.
Wait, what?
How does that work?
You think you've done something here?
granddaughter you are nothing and no one will ever remember
you not even Loki you'll just be a forgotten chapter in his
story oh he'll be too busy mourning his father he doesn't
mean that I see you again you You wish you died with your
parents.
Jesus Christ!
How is she not crying?
I'd be like...
Oh my God!
What if she comes out looking for it?
She used to leave me food?
What?
She'd say she didn't care about me.
Sometimes I'd wake up and...
I'd see a loaf of bread sitting next to the fire.
Just bake just the way she always used to.
That's drama, right?
She's not a monster, you know?
She still has her old cell.
She's lost.
Aww.
You
want to walk?
Aww.
We both fucked up.
It's okay with you.
We can heal from the trauma together.
Aww.
All this because of Jada's soul's addiction.
I just, we just want, we want, we care about her.
It was an intervention.
Holy shit.
You had a three?
Atreus.
Race me.
Come on.
I see what you're doing.
You know you want a rematch after last time.
I appreciate.
Um, last time I beat you.
I'm pretty sure we'll be tired.
Pretty sure it wasn't.
Aww.
I'm gonna try and cheer up.
We're trauma bonding.
We are.
So prove me wrong.
One, two, three, go!
Fine.
Yeah, no, that girl definitely needs a hug.
You coming or what?
What?
Go, go, go!
Oh, no, you don't.
That's right.
I thought I can control my wealth.
I have absolutely no idea what you're saying.
This field always looks so amazing.
But it's beautiful.
I assume your nose is much better like this.
Don't get too distracted.
Oh, come on.
You're not getting tired now, are you?
Okay, I can't go faster than this.
I'm literally a wolf
Translators note fuck you
The challenging bark
Playful out you really made me work for it work for it you
wrote a magic fire the whole way Loki or Atreus thank you
I'm sorry she was so hard on you me too
well I should tell it be like I will never forget you I'll
meet you by the shrine when you're ready do I have to leave
not if you don't want to your prophecy was less clear on
when you have to go oh my prophecy all right let's go repair
stuff one more time Bro, just hug already.
Just hug.
Um.
Upgrade it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have the bow.
Actually.
Yeah, we could stay in that.
Oh, shit.
I have so many now.
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm just gonna upgrade the things I have.
That's too many things to keep track of.
Agreeable grunt.
I think it's a super chat, Holly.
Thank you.
Whoa, whoa.
Bro, you scared me.
What?
I was trying to...
What are you doing behind me?
Oh, that one's my favorite.
I'm really proud of that one hand.
Like, seriously.
Look at it.
Um...
No, yeah, it's amazing hands are so hard to draw they really
are That's so true really like what you did with the colors
in this one.
Oh That dark blue pigment in the sky was really hard to nail
down.
Well, you clearly did.
Oh, you're like sharing all right tips Thank you wait.
There's the other animals They've forgotten how to find.
Oh I bring them here because they won't survive on their own
but with those soul marbles you could know I'm sorry it's
just all of this the prophecy stuff it's too much you grab
more green bulbs earlier right you can go feed the animals
if you want wait I can feed them wait how do I feed them
wait let me in oh let me in
no that's okay thank you for the Super Jack, thank you,
thank you.
Good morning from Germany.
Good morning from Canada.
Let's be like, oh, you can feed them, you know?
And I'm like, let me feed them.
That's fucked.
They baited me with that.
There's a gate?
Oh.
I can't open this gate.
Where's the gate?
There's no way.
I walked past the gate.
Was it not that gate?
I won't let me in No
Oh by the way it doesn't work By the way the gates don't
work I had so much extra food
It's not fair Why would you say I can feed Oh wait wait Hey
thanks for taking the time to find all those extra green
bulbs Oh my god I can feed the wolves i do too oh uh you're
welcome wait can i feed them wait they have their souls you
really care about them huh i do why can i feed them oh my
god why would they do this to me why why would they do this
to me that's so Fuck.
Why would they say that?
I can't even feed the animals.
The whole ass petting zoo, but with no petting.
I can't.
I
think I'm being stupid.
I think.
You care.
for your dad so much you can't conceive of a world where you
let him get hurt
come here i need to show you something huh how do you know
guys am i even halfway to this game
that's your mom right
lafay oh lafay that's my brother i wish it weren't empty but
Oh, that's my mom.
I know how it feels.
To lose a parent.
That's my mom.
To lose both.
Your mother may be gone, but your father...
You've still got time.
To say goodbye.
I know what you're trying to say.
And I appreciate it.
I do.
but
we've got to be more than a bunch of stories with our
endings already written
what happens to you now now I won't forget you
I don't know like I said once you're gone my part in this is
over you have free will now you can do whatever you want So,
you know, feel free to stay.
I think your part is as big as you want it to be.
Aww.
I mean, that's good.
I mean, it's good.
You can do whatever you want now.
Oh, my God, we're so close.
No idea.
I can't just sit back and let my dad die.
I gotta get back.
What?
A girl?
Okay.
What?
A girlfriend?
Huh.
You're with you.
No.
You just are.
I am gonna see you again.
Sure.
Okay, now.
Close your eyes.
And hold that tight.
you don't want to lose it home think of it repeat it
home home home home it's home now like that oh wait this is
not home where the oh Oh my god, wrong home.
Oh no.
He's home, home.
Whoops.
He didn't update his address.
Oh,
she was not specific in her instructions.
Oh, fuck!
He slept in the wrong bed in Minecraft.
Yeah, instructions are great.
Oh, shit.
Are you fucking...
First off, babe, bro.
Yeah, he forgot to reset his spawn, bro.
Don't you hate it when that happens?
Whoops I ran the wrong way.
Oh my gosh, and I don't even have my fucking, I don't have
my wolf.
I can't leash the beast.
Alright, fuck it, let's do it.
Alright, let's get this guy out of here.
Boom!
Okay, at least I have...
Oh!
I gotta get back to Sindris and figure out how to save
Father.
And I gotta keep Ironwood and Anger Voter a secret somehow.
Oh.
What did I get myself into?
How the fuck do I...
Oops, accidentally clicked that.
No, I mean to click that.
where's the port oh there's the portal I was gonna say where
the fuck is the portal huh oh okay I was gonna say oh oh
shit I wanted to visit Fenrir for two days I two days why
did you come here alone do you seek death no more than you
Holy shit!
The water's freaked out!
I have tried to walk this path with you.
We follow your every wind.
But you don't believe in any of it.
And still, I follow.
Because all that matters is that you are safe.
But that's not all that matters.
Oh, he's being such a dad now.
How do you know that, boy?
You sure about that?
what do you know dad caught me gaming at three in the
morning i just need you to trust me you kept secrets but i
trust you that's not the same why not you hit things mother
hit things you had good reasons and so do i why can't you
just oh
he can't tell his he can't tell his dad about his secret
girlfriend
I can get my stupid shield.
Pussies using a shield.
Goddamn, pussies!
I don't need no shield.
I said as I use my shield to shield bash.
Okay, now is the time I use fire.
Because this is an ice world.
Bomb, bomb.
Alright, nice.
Where's the last guy?
Yeah Where the fuck is Artee is not gonna shoot him?
Oh my god, who is that his guardian?
Oh my god, do not remember it Looks like the bastard's
finally done it
Oh shit Okay, we'll do that
holy shit she's so strong oh my god and i have no rage meter
too that's the worst part
are you fucking kidding me it's a fat yeah i know there you
go that's a good parry for me she's so fucking strong are
you fucking i need i wanted to grab the heels i got oh my
god i got so Breeding!
We have beaten the Valkyrie before.
We will again.
Okay.
Yeah, I had to keep my eyes on her.
Are you serious?
It's not fair she can fly!
Okay.
She's not missing a boat, is she?
Oh, what?
Oh, that just heals.
Okay.
okay focus on the enemy not me yes sir oh jesus
nice i have this again too
nice i got the barrier okay
doing it what the is okay don't touch it Nice.
All right.
I think she's free enough, like.
I don't think she cares, bro.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, it's okay.
It's just cutscene.
It's just a cutscene.
Huh?
Reya?
Wait, what?
What?
Every agony.
Every violation imaginable.
Oh, shit!
Petraeus!
You do not want this!
Call your mind!
Petraeus!
Control your rage!
That was Patchwish.
That was Freya?
She was our friend.
My bear son.
I'm strong as fuck.
I just wrestled a bear.
Control your furry son.
Oh, she realized she's a monster now.
It's after all that.
Oh!
Maybe.
For the moment.
You are of more use to me.
Alive.
Oh.
Did it.
We're friends again.
Yay!
That's right.
Home.
Really?
You will tell the truth when I return.
Now I must set things right.
Um...
We'll take him.
Oh.
Your Majesty.
A pleasure to see you again.
Bronifer.
Do not let him out of your sight.
You heard him, sunshine.
Come on, get a move on.
You killed her last son.
You owe her another one.
What is this, Hollow Knight?
What is it?
What is it you want?
We're gonna make Silk Sun.
I have feelings to remain bound to this realm.
We travel to Vanaheim.
Well, guess it's just us, then.
We're gonna make silkside.
One gateway to Vannaheim Coming right up.
Valor uses rage to You're right.
So that...
I'd rather use rage to To fight.
No, fuck that.
I'm fucking raging to fight.
Bro, what the fuck?
Well, I'm angry.
I'm not gonna use it to You're like a pussy.
I ain't no pussy.
Oh shit, I want to fucking...
I want that armor.
What the fuck?
Upgrade this later.
They're ready for strength?
That shit is fire.
More strength.
I haven't unlocked.
I should have unlocked the axis.
Yeah?
Yeah, I knew it.
Switch by pausing?
Who pauses?
Yeah, sure, I'll do that.
I have anything new here?
Yeah, imagine not mashing.
Exactly!
Alright, oh, do I have any new relics or anything?
Oh yeah, this one I just put on.
You are still bound, how will you travel?
I crafted a protection ward that'll keep me from being
pulled out of the realm.
It should hold until I find what I need.
And what is that?
me to Midgard we're going to find it and destroy it I will
help you but it will not change what I have done I know all
right why I still might kill you when this is over oh the
risk oh I'm gonna get watered I'll be right back chat let me
grab some water real quick
I think like the crazy part is that I asked you guys Like,
oh, hey, guys.
Am I at least 50%?
And you guys were like, maybe 25 to 30?
Am I 25 to 30?
Oh, my God.
Like, I was not expecting that.
NSD, J.L.C.
J .L.
C.
John, Robin, Burr.
Astro, Mafalian, Juge, Alvi.
Vinci, Nexi, Zechra, Rice, Fowar, Malkish, Medi, Alan, thank
you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my, this might be the... No, no, I have Dynasty Warriors.
Never mind.
But like, I was not expecting this game to be that long.
Ain't going nowhere without this.
Sure.
Where would you muck spouts even be without?
And I've been like doing like super long streams for this
too.
It's been good fun so far.
I've been enjoying the series, yeah.
Patrice, thank you for chatting.
Thank you for being excited to see you beat this game in
May.
But I still needed help to break them.
This one is held strong.
There, I was drinking my water.
Yeah, I've been enjoying the story so far.
I don't recall asking you to come along.
Because you didn't.
I got an old drinking buddy I've been meaning to look up.
Once this joint we're back on the map.
Folks, a hand's gonna end me up where I'm going.
And what makes you think that?
Because last I heard tell, she was running with that beef
with brother of yours.
Freya.
I'm closer to the beginning than to the end.
That's fucked.
That's crazy.
Because I felt like I made so much progress, too.
This is part three.
Really?
is the door did i pass the door oh my god i didn't even
notice i passed the gate i was so confused this is not the
gate there's gonna be no gate showing up that way you know
that bro i don't know what the gate is i was so used to just
walking in a straight line until the gate appears oh my god
All right, here we go the pool of the binding curse.
I literally ran through the gate
That's crazy Fimble winters to blame but if it helps these
two find peace this is a temporary alliance Mimir anything
beyond that would require trust.
Oh, please you know damn well Kratos isn't the true cause of
your suffering You're both as much a part of my suffering as
anyone What's over here, though?
How's about a riddle delight in the mood?
Easy, a nose.
You'll have to try harder than that, Brock.
Just you wait, smart guy.
Oh my god, I'm gonna get so lost here.
Wait, there's trees.
That's gonna need more magic than we got, Sonny.
Oh, fuck.
There's too much stuff here.
No!
There's too much.
Why is this glowing?
Oh, the axe I left in my home came back to me.
Oh, no.
Something's wrong.
What?
My spell.
I can feel it slipping.
Well, that's fimbled winner for you.
You don't understand.
I'll be torn from the realm.
What can be done?
Something I was hoping to avoid.
Seems I don't have much choice.
Falky!
Oh.
She's a bird now.
You had a way around Odin's curse this whole time.
No.
I discovered it once you unlocked realm travel.
And it solves very little.
This form is extremely limiting.
Oh, she has to be a bird now?
Do not.
I do not do it, Doki.
She is like, stop.
Also, she can travel between realms if she's a bird.
God damn it.
Watch where you're going.
The plants are extra aggressive in this humidity.
What's your talking bird?
Oh shit!
She even warned me.
And I didn't listen.
Villages would meet and trade here.
they never rebuilt i'm gonna say how did i not hit
she's just like she just just like you
brother do you really think she'll let us off the hook if
you help her i always forget he's here he's part of the
entire thing after that we will see hi
Nice.
Looks like they sure left behind a lot of goodies.
All right, back here we go.
That's one way of looking at it.
I see it.
I'm more, I'm so paranoid now.
Oh wait, I dropped now.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
What the fuck?
Oh shit, I started to dominate.
effect I was gonna say why are they all just exploding there
I swear to God where is it okay I have to be sure oh my god
I fucking knew it how was I supposed to know there's a chest
here the exploding plan dokey that's how you're supposed
They must have withdrawn, hidden themselves out in the
wilds, and covered their tracks with magic.
No way of knowing how many are left or how to reach them.
Acer ran cockshot all over this place, huh?
You can thank Mimir for that.
War with the Vanir was never my idea.
My idea was brokering the marriage to end it.
A great success that was.
This is like our people, right?
That's a disaster than the marriage.
Did he invade again?
Yeah, marriage didn't do shit.
Awesome, like back to where people are.
So after exile, he's just like, okay, back to war.
Good old old olden.
God, fucking God, damn it!
I kind of hate these plants so much Fuck these plants Thank
god there's like heal stones here Oh my god And all Freya is
doing She's just watching She's just fucking watching
I'll beat up the wolves I don't know It's all right.
We got it.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
All right, Aaron.
Now we got all the wolves.
Oh my god.
There's more!
Oh, God.
It's all right.
It mixed up.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
I thought I was like, holy kill, sir.
Okay, you can totally help out, Praia.
You can literally just come in here.
Maybe, like, Poked him a little with your little peep.
There is no way you're just watching.
Yeah, she likes to watch.
Oh, I remember your brother stirring up an awful scene.
Why do you keep bringing him up?
My brother is no concern of yours.
Do you understand?
Oh, I understand, planet.
Look, please be nice to him.
He only has three out of four souls.
He's our special dwarf.
He's blue.
She probably does like seeing Kratos get beat the shit out
of him.
That's why she's not helping.
Where was that?
Oh my god, I can't even run straight.
I swear to god.
I swear, what the fuck is that?
hey the plant life grows more dangerous the further we go
keep your up for it dwarf wait what i kept burning listen i
know how bad it oh there we go i just have to chop it when
he opens up and i were on the out so long it was like not
having a brother at all now i'd take some of the fall for
that on account of me walking out but it never stopped me
blaming him most any of this
My point is that weren't the end to all of things after all
Once we got our heads right, it was like no time He went
straight back to being as big a pain in my ass as he ever
was That's family.
You got to keep them close where they make you good and
crazy.
Why do you think I need to hear any of this right now?
My focus is on regaining my freedom and I have no intention
of being distracted Look, all I'm saying is, if you happen
to find yourself talking to your brother, maybe the worst
one said between you don't have to be the last one said.
Enough.
When the day comes to face prayer again, it will be when I
am standing on my feet and free.
Do you understand me?
It will not be while I'm stuck in this preposterous
situation.
I've got a case of pride, I get it.
Hope yours clears up quicker than mine did.
A touching story that was.
They're like, they're like fucking arguing.
Like, what's up?
Where the fuck is the last one?
Was Brock just being like, being like, just for, like, just
don't...
um just don't don't let your pain and grief consume you type
deal
are you stop where is there
where the fuck is it
is it up here it's behind i can't find it i hate oh my gosh
i hate these types of puzzles
at least I got the loot
oh there it is are you serious?
It was like it's like so far back how do I get that I don't
have range for that shit oh my god I need to start like a
fuse okay last one is as an R there you go
okay Man, that was a sneaky one.
That was a very sneaky one that they did.
What did Odin do to drive everyone away?
They literally invaded.
How much was just Mjolnir?
Can one man do this much damage?
Depends on the weapon and the man.
Mjolnir's door.
Do you not see what the fuck he did?
bro that guy is crazy what'd you find sounds shiny yeah no
i'll be surprising your people is still alive to be filled
with boats of people visiting from different villages i've
never seen it so empty
i honestly i would be surprised if any of your if your uh
any of your kind is still alive we've got company huh huh
here oh here whoops what what okay I don't know you saw what
I saw but like you just stood there so I got Very confused.
I mean, he's not getting closer.
Oh my god, there's another.
That's fine, it's fine.
I have this.
Whoa!
That's good, that's fine, that's fine.
I have this.
Boom!
What the fuck?
My guy just exploded.
I like hit him out of bounds and he disappeared.
Kratos, smash!
That's right!
Killed your husband, now I'll kill you!
Oh my!
What?
Okay, that might have been overkill.
I'm sorry, that was crazy.
Holy fuck that.
Oh my god, Kratos.
Oh, oh, wow.
Wow.
well you can't do anything with that yet it seems don't
guess i can't read yet i'm still illiterate illiterate yeah
i was jaw-dropping go that guy was just eating bro i didn't
like it
no more hell did not like the way he visitors i wouldn't
know they're not my people anymore what how are they not
your people you're still queen here i killed the vibes wait
why are they not her people anymore
oh oh he opened the passage go get him keep your guard up
not my queen we're democracy now now yeah but just exiled by
odin not like by her people
oh i see like she they see like he betrayed she betrayed
their car her kind i see now what do we have here oh one eye
send another god to do his dirty work Thor too busy.
We do not serve Odin.
No?
Picked a dangerous place for sightseeing that.
That Nicholas Cage?
All right.
Oh.
No, no.
No need for threats, brother.
Oh, what?
Oh, I know that voice.
You know, that cut off your head.
but it seems somebody beat me to it hi oh quite observant
brother oh well you're no brother of mine we sold my sister
to that oh quick oh did you now where is it it's the brother
and where is my sister it's rayon freya some dungeon in
asgard no No, she's a bird now.
Is she even alive?
Yeah?
Answer me.
I guess we'll settle for blood.
Wait, what happened?
Oh, there.
What is that?
She's a bird.
Why do you speak in her voice?
It's me, Invi.
There's no time to explain.
Just listen.
These men are in my service.
I'm here to reclaim what's been taken from me.
It's too late.
huh you can't undo what's been done i can i will now let
them pass there is plenty of time to explain what the fuck
she just flies away bro like there's so much time to explain
she just flies away you can explain instead of flying away
Women in my work.
I don't know.
She's burned!
She can't explain why she's in burn form!
Like...
There's no time.
Bro, why did she fly away?
She couldn't explain.
Oh, can it, blabber.
Come here.
That makes no sense.
You found who I was looking for.
Think I'm gonna stay and catch ya.
Oh, are ya now?
Oh, he's in love.
No, damn it.
You wouldn't mind?
I'd have a word with Lord Fair.
Yeah.
What do you think you're doing?
Just setting up shop at my fort.
Just because I hugged you, don't mean I ain't still sore,
you squabbling Sam Piper.
That's crazy.
That's looking crazy.
I'm twing.
There's no time to explain.
Flies away.
Oh,
is that squirrel girls?
That's funny.
Now, Brock, ain't you gonna take me to this tall glass of
milk you got for a bodyguard?
Of course I'm gonna.
That's Kratos.
Oh, you can call him whatever pops into your head.
Kratos?
Hmm.
We go back.
Well, I guess it's better than nothing I'm my current armor
more.
Oh, but this is better though.
I'm gonna craft Oh, okay.
Melee attacks are low luck chance to resource Chance to
grant or Chance to grant rage when damage taken.
Okay, we'll grab the actual Vitality cool down Now I'll do
that.
I already get rage I don't keep your bits and all the right
places and i can upgrade too whoa that goes hard
yeah i got that damn am i good or what all right nice are
these special items what are you looking for wait what do i
have equipped you know what you want I don't even know what
I want.
Big man.
I don't know what I want.
Now don't go get yourself killed.
Hear me?
Banana, thank you, Mr. Pritchard.
Thank you, thank you.
What do I want here?
Oh, should I have more now?
Wait, more damage?
Yeah.
Okay, we'll grab more damage.
Alright, that's good.
then oh
wait on that's fine all right we should be good here we wish
this camp kept secret understood i will not compromise it oh
that's a fat-ass dog oh my god wait that's a pig wait is
that pig or a dog no that's a dog oh my god that's a big-ass
dog you have here oh i can't even pet him servant of freya
do not speak to him i'm so sad look you chased him off i
can't even pet the dog it's a pog it's a pig dog what's the
point i can't even pet the dog sir we got off on the wrong
foot there stranger i'm pretty used to only seeing ace here
no time experience spends an hour and a block but the other
super chat that you didn't get his name is kratos and no the
acer on vanaheim yeah we've been occupied since uh i lost
count what is your plan she'll go working on it brother i
think i could be of you was that light and dark elf together
romeo and juliet your mission will go considerably smoother
without me in the mix come back for me when you're done
Wait, really?
As long as you're working for my sister, carefully you don't
screw up.
Wait, you're right!
Oh my god, the light elf being the dark elf!
Oh my god, he did the thing!
Oh my god, he did the stretch your arm.
He didn't fail the quick time event, bro.
He asked Riz.
Bro, that love was...
Oh my god, bro.
The forbidden love.
That is cute.
We got exiled for that.
Oh my god.
They're like, no!
You cannot be together.
It ain't right.
And they're like, love has no boundaries.
Why did I ask him for advice?
How the fuck did he was able to score a baddie like her?
I have words if you would hear them.
Speak then.
With anger you feel for your brother.
I know it well.
You have a brother?
His name was Demos.
When we were boys, he was taken by two gods obsessed with
prophecy.
The gods of my homeland seldom left survivors.
so by the time i learned he had lived it was too late for
amends his anger poisoned him against me but i never stopped
loving my brother you think my anger is irrational can he
kill his brother your moments and already you're taking his
side i am not taking it no you're just sharing your thoughts
on a subject you know nothing about did i kill my brother
Oh, someone else killed them.
Okay, at least it wasn't me.
I fucking...
I fucking knew it.
It wasn't me, though.
I never know if I'm...
Okay, I am going the right way.
Okay, that means there was some...
There was, like...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, I knew there was a chest here.
Is there any other way here?
Or is this just a secret?
Is there like an extra path over here I didn't see?
I want to be sure.
Wait, no.
This was the correct way.
God damn it.
I'm always so confused.
Oh wait, no.
Yeah.
Yeah, loot.
Okay, okay, thank God.
I knew it.
I knew this was the, uh, this was the loot way.
My loot senses were tingling.
Oh, we go this way.
Yeah, this map is huge.
It's pretty though.
I swear to God, I swear to God.
Okay, okay, I was gonna say, I swear to God, if he starts
fucking exploding right there.
I think the worst part is that everything looks the same on
this An ancient.
Oh.
Guys, was I not supposed to...
Are you fucking...
There you go.
Nice.
Okay.
We're good.
We're so good.
Oh, no.
Oh no, it's these guys.
Oh my god, forgot about these guys.
I hated these guys so much.
Oh fuck
There you go There you go.
Oh, oh Get on get on get on him get on him.
Yes
Okay, we oh this is not good.
This is not good though There you go
there you go oh thank god it's a wonder i've had such
difficulty killing you oh thank god okay we got free shit
yeah look that guy was literally i don't even know if he was
gonna get aggro to me or he was just minding his own
business i was just like oh can i hit him
i was just like I wonder if I can hit this guy So I have no
idea if he was just chillin I If I like I was supposed to
fight him or not Just start to fight for no he was like fuck
the trees Trying to play on my sympathies in the hope I let
you live I am only trying to help The mistakes of the past
need not be repeated.
I don't need to hear about I made enough.
He was just on a lunch break.
The wrong place wrong, Dev.
I was like, I see tree and I must punch tree.
Oh.
Okay, this guy was actually friendly.
Oh shit, never mind.
Not friendly.
all right
whoa oh my god look at that combo though
whoa yeah more more dogs oh shit jesus it came from the
water
I don't know if I like the axe beam.
Is the axe beam that good?
I don't know.
I don't know how I feel about the axe beam.
Does it actually do a lot of damage?
Yeah, it doesn't seem very good.
Fuck this tree in particular.
Yeah, it feels kind of meh.
I'm not really...
Enjoying it says like a lot of damage, but it did not feel
like a lot of damage Oh, I guess I have to use it for now
Yeah, I can't really do much about it
Everyone is so eager to advise me I lost my dog around if
you love playing late, you know I just last time I went for
a swim Saving me when I specifically told you not to but
girl they were just rich out there you think yeah i know
balder wasn't perfect but he was mine i know you know you
think you can even begin to understand the pain of losing a
child yes i do you know my story before atreus her name was
coliope coliope what happened it was long ago damn she just
assumed that's fucking right I also lost my- I lost two
wives.
And you just hit your husband.
I lost him.
I fell in love and I lost.
That's right.
Oh, I- Oh, hey.
Oh.
Never mind.
Yeah, just assuming that...
Nice, thanks.
That's right.
I showed him.
Yeah, you think you're the only one that lost the fucking...
Child
Gosh me me me me
That's right cutscene immunity Oh, and you get parry too So
embarrassing for you I get out of here go back
Are you serious if she'll there you go That's right no
shield for you
I thought that was like I was thought he looked like avatar
people at first because they were blue oh wait do they spawn
did he just did she just spawn in reinforcements is that
what she did yeah yeah she looked like blue so I thought
like I thought she looked like the Navi oh shit I not mean
that sorry it was just a little just a little angry i'm oh
my yes oh okay i thought i thought we friends i guess not i
guess we not friends it's all right you can see i kept my
anger i was like oh nice you see me to help me and i was
like no i'll come here kill you kill you myself
I guess like Jokes on me for thinking he's friend shape
Oh shit Beam Bro that beam fucking sucks No that shit sucks
No that shit Nah that Nah Yeah I'm definitely I'm thinking
that shit off Yeah
Oh, fuck.
Jesus.
Nope.
No more alpha in the forest.
My forest now.
That's right.
My territory now.
But yeah, no, that.
That shit.
That beam was shit.
I'm going to swap it back to my regular, the one I used
before.
I know your son's story.
You should know my daughter.
That's right.
I'm trauma-jumping.
I was tricked into destroying a village.
Not knowing my own wife and child were there until their
blood stained my hands.
I swore revenge.
That's...
I can't imagine.
Yeah, see, that's worse, right?
My trauma's worse than your trauma.
To the ground.
Perhaps you will kill me, Preya.
But it will bring you no peace.
Perhaps it is not peace.
i seek all those times i found you why'd you refuse to fight
me every outcome would mean defeat what does that mean i
have never wished you harm treya you helped us you saved
atreus when he was sick i did not wish to live with killing
you any more than i wished to die i see
it absolutely is a competition my trauma is worse than your
trauma and look i i'm okay you know i'm okay
what's that
oh god destroy the fucking noken then what the i could not
even dodge that Holy shit.
Okay, beam!
Stupid ass beam.
Yeah, it jumps me hard.
Iron ice beast scraps.
Those are good upgrade shit.
That's over here.
Oh, nothing.
What the fuck?
They put this little thing here.
It's nothing?
My village.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't think there's anyone here.
I used to play hide and seek the fair in the crops.
We spend afternoon stealing honey bread from the Grand Hall.
At harvest time, we dance and feast until the sun leaves.
Oh.
It was all so simple.
Why did I have to come back to you?
Be reminded of all this.
Oh.
Poor Freya.
It's in ruin.
We're trauma bonding.
Weed.
May Freya never waver.
The other half is missing.
May she protect us always.
An old adage, if you will.
You can get through over here!
Oh, yeah.
Okay, but what if there's loot over here?
I'll make sure.
I knew it.
I knew it for you.
You try to get me away from my loot?
My precious loot.
Okay, I should be able to get here somewhere.
I smell the chest.
Wait, where?
Where's the place that I can get through?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
Yeah, you try to...
What?
There we go, there we go, there we go, that worked, that
worked.
I got it, I got it, though.
I got it, though.
It's okay, I got it in the end.
Why is there, like, a magic thing?
Oh, here.
Okay, I don't...
Missed it.
A hitter?
I can't tell.
No, I did not.
Okay, yeah, wait, wait.
Okay, I missed my entire beam.
That is a little embarrassing.
All right, we have to get to the archer, man.
Just to be sure that she doesn't summon more.
Whoa!
Yeah, no more!
Okay.
Get out of here.
That's right.
I used this pair against you.
There you go.
He comboed!
I'm gonna bash her up combo time this there's more oh my god
she's some oh my god we're the fuck that this person oh my
god she ran all the way here like a fucking pussy wait
that's not her we're in is she?
Wait, which one is she?
Oh wow, I'm so confused.
I don't know which one is a goddamn stupid archer.
I'm so sad.
I don't know where she is.
I actually don't know where the Fuck the archer is.
I'm just gonna fucking...
I'm just gonna kill it.
Are you serious?
That's it.
I'm raging.
I'm just gonna get rid of this guy first.
And then I'm gonna stop being angry and I'm gonna find her.
There she is.
This has to be her.
That's right.
You ain't standing no more reinforcing.
can't do archery now when you have no arms he's desecrated
every memory I have of home be glad you have a home to
remember fondly oh yeah I destroyed my home we were taken
from our homes as children and raised in the a goji we
marched or we drowned fought for scraps or starved our
elders beat us till we cannot stand this is not a
competition alone Let her fucking vent!
That is how Spartans are made.
What?
Bro, let her vent!
Bro, that's a fuck.
He's like, oh, you think you had it bad?
Okay, nah, I didn't stop.
It's not, but he is winning.
cannot be, he can't lose any fight of me.
He's like, stop complaining, bitch.
It's a trauma-dumping competition.
And I don't think anyone's winning.
Oh, no, Kratos is definitely winning, JK.
No, he is definitely winning this.
Anything here?
Okay, she wants me to go this way.
I shall go this way.
Even in trauma, he is the strongest.
He really is.
All right, let's go this way.
Oh, why blue?
These plants behave similarly to the scorn poles we found in
the foothills of Midgard ages ago.
Oh, that's why it blew.
Wait, we're a bird.
Oh, bird here.
Well, considering how Spartans are made, it's no wonder you
turned out as you did.
Your fate was sealed from the start.
Fate can be overcome.
I used to think so.
When the Norns told me of my son's fate, I thought I could
change it.
You know well how that worked out the lords the fates of
these lands.
That's right You defy prophecy at your own peril
No, no no
I saw loot Where where did it send me?
Okay, here It faded me with loot Finally, to the scorn poles
we found in the foothills of Midgard ages ago.
Well, considering how Spartans are made, it's no wonder you
turned out as you did.
Agreed.
I got to agree.
Brows, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, this is the one that goes to your friend and say, Be
happy you have a family.
What?
You know how that worked out.
The Norns.
The fates of these lands.
That's right.
He faded me.
at your own i saw chess and i was like i'm gonna bunga me
likey
all right up we go the trace would agree with you about
prophecy he rushes blindly to a fate the giants foretold
this is my day with a super chat thank you thank you i know
all the ragnarok prophecies there's no champion of the
giants it is one because of this champion the realms are
saved at Ragnarok only as God falls and Odin with it so all
this time Odin's obsession with every detail of Ragnarok
he's been missing a crucial piece well done well the trace
will not be a pawn of prophecy you still stand against fate
you will be his own person I will not march my son to war he
is no spartan i would keep it that way damn he will choose
his own destiny even if it's a destiny i do not approve of
protecting your child is my tragedy not enough of a lesson
fighting fate is a waste of the precious time we're given to
spend with them okay you want me to go this way so i go this
way if he wishes to be a wolf i shall accept him if he
wishes we will not let prophecy dictate his fate his
prophecy didn't think he would want to be a wolf and that is
enough for me
how did I do
okay what about the crane can you turn it somehow I'm
literally turning it oh and then I light it oh I'm lighting
it oh I'm lighting it oh my god you can probably use those
islands to get a better angle on the torch no
oh my god what the
is it letting it what the am i okay
me confused
Yeah, that's not pushing it.
Alright, now do that.
And they'll swing, right?
I fucking...
I don't fucking know.
Bro, I...
Oh, my God.
Why can't I...
Okay, wait.
Wait, can I actually drop down?
It won't let me drop down.
oh my god it's here okay i was so confused but it was right
here all along all right there we go okay like this first
and then like this
and then oh okay come on bro
There we go.
Okay, I couldn't push up.
I have to push... I'll push down to me.
Let's cross the bridge now.
Okay, give me a sec, Freya.
Where's the last one, though?
I like this one.
But where's the...
I'm going to have to bring this over again.
Oh, it's down there.
All right.
How can you, of anyone alive, be squeamish about war?
After all the gods you've killed.
I have seen enough war to know the cost.
I'm retired.
I'm no longer the god of war.
I'm a god of dads.
Yeah, more health.
I'm retired.
You know, like war no more.
I'm the god of dads, yeah.
Yeah, too much trauma.
That's one of Odin's captains.
Be ready.
Oh, this guy?
Okay.
Oh my god, what are you...
I got it wrong first.
I got it first.
I got it first
Okay, that's fine Nice, oh shit nice No, I didn't get the
third second one.
Oh, I didn't get it, but I can do this now
Okay, that's bullshit
Are you fucking cute?
Okay, I got the Parry for it, though.
Get parry!
Oh my god, I didn't miss that.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's bullshit!
I got blocked!
Okay, this time.
Okay, nice.
It's red.
You know what that means?
Rage time!
Oh, wait.
All right.
but then you're rage.
Jesus.
He was his captain?
That scout was easy as hell.
Bro.
Don't quit your day job.
Bro, that guy...
I think Odin needs to find new recruitment.
It was not that difficult for a captain of his army.
I mean...
Back
what you have lost any more than killing me.
I am reaching my limit.
Okay, she wants me to go that way, so I go the opposite
direction.
Can you please just shut up and kill things?
Whoa, whoa, chill, chill.
Why not?
I'll do it eventually.
You know, I literally just killed the captain.
It'll happen, girl.
It'll happen.
Yeah, is this your king?
Please, Preya.
Please, let me have some loot.
I literally just killed the captain of the Odin's army.
When it wants to be an arrow prank treatment, I think it's a
super chatty.
Then I must accept it.
It'll just be a phase.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay, I can do this puzzle.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm just back where I started, right?
No, this is a puzzle.
Okay, so I can't do anything here.
Oh, oh, you used that.
Ha, you almost got me.
Oh, you thought you got me there, huh?
Ha, ha.
I fucking saw it right through you.
That's fucking red.
I saw it.
I saw what you wanted to do.
That's right.
He almost got me there.
Almost.
Oh, he should have grown.
Yes, more loot.
More loot, please.
More loot.
Okay, cool.
Hey, more loot.
Look, loot, loot.
What is there here?
Oh, that's where I have to go.
Okay, but what is this then?
What is this for?
What the fuck?
Wait, did I just hear dog barking?
Oh, for more loot!
Of course!
But...
A fucking...
course are you oh my god okay okay we gotta figure this out
oh my god oh my god oh okay okay i thought i was gonna
fucking fall through that how do i get that
what oh my god oh my god oh my god I could have swung it the
other way okay I understand I understand guys me understand
I I'm using my brain I'm using my brain there we go there we
go yeah yeah I got it
all right it's like only one way I'm so smart guys Oh yeah I
forgot to tell this story But like For the longest time
Every time I use the bathroom and wash my hands Like I was
smelling like Thai food When I was like washing my hand I
was like why the fuck am I Like is there something happened
in my sink Like why am I smelling Thai Like like Is there's
like do I need to get my plumbing fixed or something shit
and then i finally found out i forgot all about this but i
bought gingerbread soap and and apparently when i washed my
hands the gingerbread smells like Thai food to protect my
son to aid my friends but I will be no one's monster never
again you don't get to make that choice not with it's like
freaking me out I was like here for debts I would always
have helped you so much because i thought it was really i
thought it was funny it's like gingerbread so i don't know
why apparently it doesn't even smell like gingerbread it
smells like fucking thai food it smells like thai curry
whenever i wash my hands and i was like freaking out because
i was like what is wrong with my sink
why are you wasting your time with that our path is in the
opposite direction cars lose i want to lose yeah i was like
did i have covet or like or some i was so freaking out i was
freaking obvious i was like i don't know and it's because
like i recently changed my hand i ran out of hand soap so i
was like oh i'm gonna time to use my new hand soap and then
literally every time and i legitimately thought that like
something i fucked up with my sink or some i feel the source
of the magic keeping me in midgard what is this place my
home i was born here oh the race looks like a girl you when
you're born here
hold on and damn you live you used to live like this
no rick thank you the super chat thank you thank you just
got home from play there's a lot of turbulence that probably
could watch a doki stream and here i am i'm glad you're i'm
glad Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, this is the the curse.
Oh What the fuck Well, did we break it?
Need home the creature it belongs to Odin no it protects
Igrasil's roots wherever they are Bastard was counting on it
That's it.
Don't forget.
Oh shit.
There you go five Wait, did he destroy it though?
Oh, he did it, right?
Oh, my God.
That is legal.
What do you mean?
Don't just, I'm fucking okay.
I'm doing the best I can.
I need to get to those roots.
You have indetention now.
Don't lose it.
Oh, yeah.
I'm trying very hard now.
There you go.
Bad boy.
Down.
Down, boy.
That's fucking me.
right okay now that i dragged him out here holy
yeah let me hit your fucking arm i guess i'd fucking hate
that move use your legs i'm trying holy what do you think
i'm doing Like, use your legs.
Yeah, like.
Okay.
Like, what do you think I'm doing, girl?
If I'm not using my legs.
Okay.
There you go.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
I don't even know.
I don't think I parry that.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
There we go.
Is my time is still off?
Yeah, I know.
I'm trying.
Oh, my God.
She's acting like I'm not trying to fight for my life right
now.
Yo, bro, just parry.
Bro, just, oh, my God.
She is the ultimate backseater.
He's basically.
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, wait.
In Vanaheim, yes, but there are more hoops.
She will guard them with her life.
Okay.
It's fine.
The only thing I know about a nidhogg is...
Oh, Pia, thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
It's from that nidhogg game.
Oh, that's...
It's the giant snake!
Wait, is that...
That's the worm, right?
But yeah, thank you for the rape.
I hope you had a good stream.
Oh, God.
Oh, fucking God.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
Oh my god, bro.
Again?
I Swear to God.
Yeah, see I parried.
I parried.
See, I told you I could parried.
See, I could parry.
Okay.
Oh, I did it.
I did the thing.
That's right.
Get off of that shit.
Using high ground.
Stupid.
No high ground for you.
Only I can have high ground.
But I can be angry.
I gotta grab this first before I get angry.
Angry time!
That's fucking right!
I don't feel no pain no more!
I trauma jumped already!
Jesus, what the fuck?
Whoa!
Yeah.
Oh my god, now he climbed onto that shit a fucking course.
Oh fuck!
That's okay.
Okay, I have to be able to actually have to parry this shit.
I don't I don't have to parry this shit Okay I see it
Are you serious?
Okay Fuck you What?
Okay, there you go.
Your axe!
Aim for my sigils!
I'm...
He's blocking his John ass hat!
His head was blocking it!
Yes!
It's working!
Okay, it's fine.
It is more desperate!
Yes, be ready for anything!
One fucking head was blocking it.
It's not fair.
Boom.
I had no signal for that!
There you go.
That's fine.
We're doing it.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Okay.
Some little head bash.
Are you?
Oh Oh Oh, ha ha ha ha ha ha You dodge
That's right Oh god, that's fine I dodged it I'm better, I'm
so much better than you Boom!
Oh god That's fine, that's fine, he dodged it We're gaming
Yes!
Let's go!
Zero deaths!
Let's fucking go.
We're so much better.
That's the time that they've been searching.
I downloaded him!
Wait, there's more?
Oh.
What?
It's longer.
What do you mean?
We gotta finish this!
Okay.
It's opening his stomach again!
Get ready!
I'm getting ready!
Oh my god, I was not getting ready.
Oh my god.
Oh, am I supposed to block it?
Oh, there you go.
Oh my god, I ended with rage!
Pre-therapy!
And then I'm no longer on green key yes there we go rage
time get back here I wasn't done with you that's fucking get
back here okay where is she throwing your pockets at okay oh
shit
Oh my god!
Think he's dead?
You think he's okay?
That was a strong ass block instead.
Can't tell.
Maybe he had to...
Oh yeah, he's a loser.
He'll regenerate.
are connected to, like, the places she can't visit.
Can you help?
Oh,
please help.
You're free now.
Oh.
Is it done?
It's over.
You're free.
You can go wherever you want to go.
You're welcome.
And now that you have what you seek.
I suppose...
Yeah, she got banned.
This is the point.
She submitted it on banned request.
Yes?
No.
How have you decided?
Magical scissors.
Huh?
To be honest.
I don't think I can do either.
Oh.
There's still a part of me.
That is so...
angry.
That it'll always be!
It'll always be!
angry but
no she's gonna remember this anchor for fifth till she dies
Odin yeah you set anger out on Odin that's what I do I do
see that that's why I rage on gentle music starts playing
everything that's happened between us no need to explain not
to me not for that
oh i
do not regret saving your life and never will but the choice
between life and death should have been yours to make i
should not have robbed you of that choice
friendship now
want to kill me no more.
Yay.
That's good.
I'm going to upgrade to unlock more slots.
Find elements.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Myself again.
I suppose it's time.
Oh, now it's time to exploit.
Now there's time.
to explain.
I guess it might be weird to explain while you're in bird
form.
Let me live with that for a moment.
More upgrades.
Yeah.
Oh, now I completed the tutorial.
Maxi, Simon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whenever the camera passes, she'll create us in the
backgrounds.
I always hear mama through us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
More stuff to loot.
Not yet.
Rick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
this is god of war when are we fighting goku whenever kratos
goes to the goku dimension uh thank you super chat didn't
thank you these are friends now i freed her take this way
back to the camp i can help with the vines oh now unfed your
blades into the glowing vines and light it oh oh oh oh light
it on fire
I didn't finish I didn't finish listening Oh, I'm sure he'd
love nothing Yeah, she's very calm now I think he's just
like Processed everything Oh,
so that's what it is Oh, that means she's in certain areas
Freya will be with me Yeah She sounds a lot sweeter now Now
that she's not trapped in bird form i guess when she was a
bird she was like super bitchy because i guess it's not i
guess she didn't like being a bird choose single arrows at
burning her frosted enemies to trigger an elemental oh
that's cool
right but i have to use that means i have to use that
incoming right side There you go.
Oh, shit, bro.
That's sick.
Okay.
Oh, I can use either ice.
That's good to know.
It's like...
Because I like using my axe more.
Oh my god, he's rolling down.
You think he's dead?
Alright, there you go.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah, that's fucking... Are you deserved that?
Get comboed!
Where is he?
Yeah!
Oh shit, that was sick.
All right, now I got a rock for you.
Yeah!
Send Odin my regards.
You use your anger effectively.
Oh, he's just like me!
Oh my god, we're bonding with anger.
We're anger bonding.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want to be angry with Freya.
He's my brother.
He was the most important person in the world to me.
For half my life.
You're fucking stupid.
I'm trying to fucking listen to lore.
I'll just burn this real quick.
Um, just wearing mean greet and voice chat tomorrow's uh in
VR VR chat is still going on uh oh yeah I mentioned it in
the community post um I think I mentioned on my the day
after my community post uh but it is it is rescheduled
because uh Merit is still trying to fix her uh VR stuff so
we're gonna wait until she has that all fixed before we can
figure out the date
all right
can i burn this wait okay no now the sigil should hold the
frost even in the axe's absence ah the sigils can't hold
forever let's try again what you just said to adjust our
strategy since there's more than one let's try using a sigil
oh i'm so stupid i'm so all right it's frozen let's take
care of the rest
oh i'm so stupid oh my god i'm special i
I was like, oh, and I still didn't get it.
I got it now.
Yeah, I understand.
I was like, I get it.
I did not.
But I get it now.
I get it now.
Oh my god.
Bro, I can't, I'm already, like, I'm gonna just gonna beat
up these fucking flying orbs.
I have to beat this up.
I'm like, I have so little HP from standing in the frost
because I did not get it.
I never think of this place as home again.
After all that's happened.
What the fuck is this there?
Oh my god, that means I will have to backtrack to this area
too.
What the fuck?
Skull and Hardy are in Vanaheim.
Did he just destroy the moon?
The giants rescued them from Odin and brought them here.
And look.
The sunlight wakes the sleeping roots.
See how they stretch to welcome the sun.
Oh.
Beautiful, no.
A far cry from the sheets of Midgard snow.
Is this woes?
There's the woes.
Oh, yeah, it's the wolves from the prophecy or from the
lore.
At least the whole realm hasn't fallen to predators and
occupiers.
That is beautiful.
Something to be fought for here.
Something to defend even after so much damage.
The moon was like, oh, shit.
Maybe that goes for Freyr, too.
That is beautiful.
Yeah, we saw that in the beginning of the game.
That's pretty funny.
The moon's like, fuck!
They're back!
All right, what are these?
What the fuck is that?
Stupid goddamn plants.
Kratos, I see something.
What?
You won't be able to damage it without destroying the
mother.
It's a large bulbous thing.
You can't miss it.
This?
That's a large bulbous thing.
There we go.
I was gonna say that has to be it.
It was my fucking thing just didn't have range.
I think it was just destroy it.
what is this i don't know but giants definitely crafted it
there's two wolves represented here perhaps a connection to
our friends in the sky a mystery for another time yes two
wolves that chased the thingy all
right down we go
axe and disabled shields oh my sigils can break through Oh
shit, nice!
Nice!
Are we to Elemental?
Try...
And then...
Oh!
I should have tried that.
Next time.
And by next time, me now!
Whoa!
Oh my god, but fuck these guys though.
Yeah.
Wait, where is my thing?
Oh my god, I have no HP right now.
This is really bad, actually.
Oh, please tell me you give it HP.
I am very poor right now.
Oh, please tell me you have HP.
I really need HP.
No!
Enemy behind you, Kratos.
It's okay.
Oh my god, one of you must have HP!
Where am I?
Oh, there's shit.
Oh, nice, that's good.
What?
That's okay!
That is not good!
That is absolutely not good!
Okay, okay.
This is bad.
This is actually bad.
It is no longer good.
Oh, guys, let's get him out of it.
Let's get him out of it.
I am so low HP right now.
Oh, fuck all guns, don't replace.
Enemy to your left.
What?
Okay.
I'm staying over here.
Oh, this is the last.
That's good.
Guys, I am not using...
saying yeah yeah oh god it's all right just a little almost
got a heart attack no no i gotta save it guys who wait we
might have a boss fight later guys we gotta save it i'm not
even sure where to begin what do you want from him an
apology would be a start i want to forgive him i'd like to
think he's changed He's all I have left now.
Jeremy, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh, we had a good stream.
It is difficult to seek forgiveness when you feel unworthy.
Oh, are you back home yet?
Now, how to get across?
Chain elements to where it's hard, and they grow in size and
grow bigger when chained together.
My sigil arrow should be able to carry the fire across the
river to reach the bramble.
I knew it.
I knew there was loot here.
else would there be a random place here okay play sigil
think larger and brighter when connected and then here
is that big enough
oh my god okay okay let me let me think
I can't reach it
Wow what if
I'll be able to reach it eventually right Okay
Okay, it's fine.
It is fine.
I can't reach that.
What do you mean, swing over?
Look at this.
Wait.
Wait, I'll get it.
I'll get it.
Surely.
I don't get it.
What can I touch?
Can I touch this?
Oh my god, I get it.
I get it now.
I get it.
I get it!
Oh my god, I got it!
For the unworthy.
My wife, Faye, taught me that.
Hmm.
Well, be glad you have a spouse to remember fondly.
Spouses.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Did you see me?
Oh, unleash poison?
Wait, I just use this.
Oh, shit, that's the poison.
Nice.
Wait, Freya's OP.
I fucking don't trust this shit.
Bro, she's so sure.
She has fucking poison, too?
Oh, my God.
Oh, rage!
Rage!
There you go.
It's fine.
I got rage.
Oh my god, I got more rage.
Why do none of them give HP?
Wait, there's HP right here.
Okay, nice.
I should kill him automatically.
Oh, thank god, now they give HP.
Oh.
Thank God.
I feel like I was...
I swear to God, I was playing with like 0 HP for that entire
time.
Yeah!
Uh.
TP!
Left or right?
I go...
This way.
There was no hidden loot this time.
yeah I time for the brother and sister meaning wait no I'm
going the right way I'm not going the right way I see the
numbers going getting further and further
I was like, Luke Kickoff is like, why are the numbers going
up?
That's weird.
I'm going the right way now.
Yay.
I just...
Okay, now...
Now I should be going...
the right way what
yeah was that there's no limit to the depths to which a soul
can sink into darkness tricked me into marriage to spare my
home and took my home just the same scattered my people to
the wind maybe it's time somebody drew the line maybe it's
time someone makes grow as Okay, but does anyone actually
like Odin though?
I would not wish for war, Freya.
War is a terrible thing, Kratos.
But some things are even worse.
You know, if Atreus rushes to Ragnarok, you may not be able
to stop him.
I will.
And if you fail?
I have prepared him to survive without me, if he must.
Raven Crooks.
Aw, he's watching.
Aw.
Always watching.
Oh my gosh, swear to God, am I going backwards again?
I have to, I don't trust myself.
No, it's fine.
Okay, it's here.
Oh, yeah, loot.
Watch for the plants.
They like me, but strangers, not so much.
I see that.
the right way this time god damn it i swear to god i will
hit this there we go that's her get out of here i don't get
anything from this but i stop Fuck you guys.
I know I could just ran past it, but you don't fuck that.
This was worth it.
Oh, I was here.
Oh, I'm literally just going backwards.
And let me even burn this.
No.
What's this then?
We don't have the equipment for this.
Unlucky.
What's next for you?
If not preparing for war.
Now fuck those plants.
I'm not going to lose to Salad.
With Atreus.
Well, you may want to think fast unless you want someone to
make that choice for you
Ready as I ever will be all right time to talk to your
brother
Hello Confrontation time
It really is you You've returned to us at last yes uh let's
celebrate you reclaim the throne will rebuild me and you
against the world huh just like the old days i'm not staying
huh i don't understand yeah you're here maybe together we
can take back what's ours i only just got back what's mine i
still have work to do i thought you were gonna explain to
him you've seen what's left of the realm right do we really
mean that little to you you question my loyalty Vannaheim
turned its back on me oh you still can't let go of that old
fight it was my duty to save as many of our people there's
no time one you didn't take seriously then and from the
looks of it one you don't now you think this is a game to me
yeah where's my loot chest we lost everything to that maniac
you called husband the man's family set me on fire how did
you expect me to react like my brother like the boy that
used to have my back no matter what and who i always
supported no matter how selfish his choices.
Oh.
I expected you to come and find me.
That no matter how hurt or angry, you wouldn't abandon me.
Freya, please.
I
thought you were dead.
Yeah.
I've had to live lifetimes.
But those last awful words I said to you have any idea of
what that's like knowing that your own selfishness hurt the
person that you cared about the most abandon you oh Freya am
I getting gaslighted I mourned you
oh I've missed you so much oh okay no no we're fine no oh
we're fine we're fine we're fine
but i won't find myself to another realm when i finally have
my freedom i'll send help though and i will come back yeah i
promise in your home for a long time hasn't he hugged
everything is okay now
not just siblings so that's so awkward like they're all just
watching this happen all right all right that's enough ain't
y 'all got nothing better to do than gock yeah come on you
do i'm gonna say that's so awkward we're just all watching
this not you
yeah got a few things to square with y'all first is you
collecting your spare head uh second is that sigil magic I
smell on your bow my bow I reckon that's an idea I'll steal
how's about I set you up with some sonic mojo call it a
trade very well third of all even you ain't staying here
bears mentioning that cindy and i find ourselves running a
flop house for unemployed gods if you're done freezing your
backside off in midgard maybe come back with beard oh there
check up on your old pal tier that's kind of you bro it's
calling me i was like all right then i'll meet y'all back at
the house lesson you all nice oh he's sonic Don't run off
without me now brother.
God damn it stupid head.
It's like not letting me grab my loot Well, brother care to
meet our new life.
Do you think he was a stupid chat?
Thank you.
Oh my god, but the stupid head was preventing me from
grabbing my loot All right, I think this is a good time to
call it guys I mean, we made a lot of, we finally got the
50% of the game.
We made it.
We actually, oh.
12, wait, was that 12 hours?
Oh, 13 hours.
And we are at 50% of the game.
Oh my god.
That's a fun so far.
I've been enjoying, um, I've been enjoying the stories so
far.
Close to no.
up close as close as 50 as we can get but um i had a break
time with god of war so far um it has been a very fun very
fun series uh very fun like unraveling the story as we go
and i'm definitely i'm getting better better at at paris
yeah the game is a great pretty great movie game um thank
you the super chat rice thank you thank you i'm gonna call
here i'm i'm epee period is still very epee um next week's
schedule most likely you know um more god of war maybe part
final part of mail gear solid um and they gave me a date for
it but i don't remember if i confirmed it or not so i'm just
gonna i'll message her real quick and be like yeah that's
cool i don't remember i i have so many messages going on so
that's like the only thing i i can fully confirm Oh, Project
Zomboid for members.
Last Project Zomboid stream for members is on Monday.
We're going to have a big battle royale.
I'm going to enable friendly fire.
And then we're all going to start shooting each other.
And I will be on God mode.
I'll be sending zombies out.
So if you're a member, our last Project Zomboid stream is on
Monday.
And then we'll back to our regular.
I think after that, the next member stream will be a Men in
Black watch along.
Because I really want to watch Men in Black.
And it's been a very, I've been craving Men in Black.
like doing a watch a lot of men in black um anyway as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and around get
that blood flow and if you stay up for me head to bed cause
you deserve it i am very ep now i'm very ep i my voice is
very dead um anyway guys bye everybody bye